You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye and health conditions at early stages. To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an
你知道吗，你的眼睛承受了很多。每天阅读、在昏暗的光线下看东西、长时间盯着屏幕，这些我经常遇到。开车时刺眼的阳光，甚至夜间驾驶都会导致眼睛疲劳。所以，是的，我们的眼睛负担很重。因此，定期进行眼科检查以呵护并监测眼睛健康非常重要。在 Specsavers 进行眼科检查，价格仅需 99 美元起，其中包括 OCT 眼部健康扫描，有助于在早期阶段发现眼部和健康状况。要查找您附近的门店并预约眼科检查，请访问
OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers.ca. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. It's always fun to learn something new, don't you think? Lady, this is a thing about you that I love, which is that you're almost determined to learn something new all the time. Like, I think it keeps you young. That's what you've said, keeps the brain fresh, Keep you curious. I know. You always inspire me. Well, if you like learning new things, you have got to check out Masterclass.
OCT 扫描 99 美元起，请访问 specksavers.ca。眼科检查由独立验光师提供。价格可能因地点而异。学习新东西总是很有趣，你不觉得吗？Lady，这是我喜欢你的一点，那就是你几乎总是下定决心要学习新东西。我觉得这让你保持年轻。你就是这么说的，让大脑保持新鲜，让你保持好奇心。我知道。你总是激励我。好吧，如果你喜欢学习新事物，你一定要看看 Masterclass。
We've talked about it before in the podcast. It's such an amazing volume of ways to learn new things from the experts of the field. Yeah, I mean, if you have a commute to work, you can turn that into a classroom, basically. They have audio mode, so you can just listen to lessons anytime, anywhere, while you're working out. And they also have thousands of short, easy-to-digest lessons. So you don't even need a long time to learn something new. Right now, our listeners get an additional 15% off any annual membership at masterclass.com slash office ladies.
我们在播客中之前提到过。这里有海量的学习资源，可以向各领域的专家学习新知识。是的，我的意思是，如果你有通勤时间，基本上可以把它变成一个课堂。他们有音频模式，所以你可以随时随地听课，比如在锻炼的时候。他们还有成千上万个简短、易于消化的课程。所以你甚至不需要很长时间就能学到新东西。现在，我们的听众在 masterclass.com/officeladies 购买任何年度会员资格，均可额外享受 15% 的折扣。
That's 15% off at masterclass.com slash office ladies. Masterclass.com slash office ladies. Welcome to your second drink of dinner party. This is such a great breakdown. We got so many audio clips from our cast for this episode. We got Steve Correll, John Cresensky, Rain, Wilson, Ed Helms, Malora Hardin, Beth Grant. Plus, we got tidbits from the director Paul Feig and writers, Gene Stupnisky and Lee Eisenberg. It's an epic episode.
在 masterclass.com/officeladies 享受 15% 的折扣。Masterclass.com/officeladies。欢迎来到“晚宴”的第二杯。这次的解析太棒了。我们为这一集收到了很多演员的音频片段。我们有史蒂夫·卡瑞尔、约翰·卡拉辛斯基、雷恩·威尔森、艾德·赫尔姆斯、梅洛拉·哈丁、贝丝·格兰特。此外，我们还有来自导演保罗·费格和编剧吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格的趣闻。这是一集史诗般的剧集。
And we also discussed more about the dinner party episode in our Office Lady 6.0 episode, Dinner Party Horror Stories. I was a little stumped as to what we might be able to add to the discussion in this second drink, but then I thought, why don't we read more of the fan letters from our submissions from dinner party horror stories? Yes, there were so many good ones. If you remember, we ask you all to send in your own dinner party horror stories and you guys really delivered. I'm going to start us off with one from Becca J. in Tennessee. Okay. Becca says, when applying for medical residences, it's common to have a dinner with current residents. This way, everyone gets a sense of the culture, and if you like them, and vice versa. Like many of the group, I ordered a glass of wine.
我们还在我们的 Office Lady 6.0 剧集《晚宴恐怖故事》中讨论了更多关于“晚宴”这一集的内容。我当时有点困惑，在这一杯中我们还能增加什么讨论，但后来我想，为什么我们不读更多来自《晚宴恐怖故事》投稿的粉丝来信呢？是的，有很多很棒的来信。如果你还记得，我们请大家寄来你们自己的晚宴恐怖故事，你们真的做到了。我要从田纳西州的 Becca J. 的来信开始。好的。Becca 说，在申请医学住院医师时，通常会与现任住院医师共进晚餐。这样，每个人都能感受到文化，看看你是否喜欢他们，反之亦然。像小组中的许多人一样，我点了一杯酒。
Then I quoted Michael Scott and said, I was getting an okey afterbirth. Unfortunately, my dinner companions were not familiar with the U.S. office, including an Aussie who complained about the show after I explained my weird phrase. Ultimately, I matched. at that program and I made great friends and I introduced the office to many residents. I mean, could you imagine the crickets if you said your wine had an oaky afterbirth to people who didn't get the inside joke, the office reference? I mean, this is a room full of residence. What if some of them are like OBGYNs? And they're like, what is happening? Well, I liked this one from Madeline O who said one time, my husband and I were invited
然后我引用了迈克尔·斯科特的话说，我喝到了橡木味的余味。不幸的是，我的晚餐同伴不熟悉美版《办公室》，包括一个澳大利亚人，在我解释了我这个奇怪的短语后，他还抱怨了这部剧。最终，我匹配到了那个项目，我结交了很棒的朋友，并向许多住院医师介绍了《办公室》。我的意思是，你能想象如果你对那些不懂这个内部梗、不懂《办公室》引用的人说你的酒有“橡木余味”时，那种冷场吗？我的意思是，这是一个满屋子的住院医师。如果他们中有些人是妇产科医生呢？他们会想，发生了什么事？好吧，我喜欢 Madeline O 的这个故事，她说有一次，我和我丈夫被邀请
to our neighbor's house for dinner. She is single and mid-60s, and she had invited us and a few other neighbors our age to come. She provided all the food, had the best dishes out. It was a very fancy and proper occasion. Everyone was chatting quietly while we were just finishing our dinner in her dining room, and there was a knock. She said, oh, the entertainment is here. It was a clown. She had hired a clown to come entertain us millennials. The cringe for me right now is like I can barely handle it. Madeline said, we were all very weirded out, but we sat politely in the living room while the clown gave us a performance clearly made for a fourth grader's birthday party. Oh my gosh. Eventually, the clown left. Needless to say, we never had another dinner party with her.
去邻居家吃晚饭。她是单身，60 多岁，她邀请了我们和其他几位同龄的邻居来。她提供了所有的食物，拿出了最好的餐具。这是一个非常讲究和正式的场合。当我们在餐厅刚吃完晚饭时，大家都在安静地聊天，这时有人敲门。她说，哦，娱乐节目来了。是一个小丑。她雇了一个小丑来招待我们这些千禧一代。我现在感到尴尬得简直无法忍受。Madeline 说，我们都感到非常奇怪，但我们礼貌地坐在客厅里，看着小丑表演了显然是为四年级学生生日派对准备的节目。天哪。最终，小丑离开了。不用说，我们再也没有和她一起吃过晚饭。
Oh, there's so much about this. There's so much about this. There's so much about this. first of all, clown's just doing his or her job. Right. That's what they do. They do clown parties for fourth graders. Yes. So imagine the clown guy, like, you have a real choice in this moment. Do I go so hard and fully commit?
哦，关于这个有很多可说的。关于这个有很多可说的。关于这个有很多可说的。首先，小丑只是在做他或她的工作。对。这就是他们做的。他们为四年级学生做小丑派对。是的。所以想象一下那个小丑，就像，你在这一刻有一个真正的选择。我是该全力以赴并完全投入吗？
Right. Or do I back off a little because I realize maybe I'm not the clown they wanted to hire? Or am I like, fuck you guys. Are you pranking me? Here's the thing I know about clowns is that they take clowning very seriously. I mean, there's like clown colleges. Oh, I know. So I have to imagine that this clown just committed.
对。还是我该稍微退缩一点，因为我意识到也许我不是他们想雇的小丑？还是我会想，去你们的。你们在捉弄我吗？关于小丑，我知道的一件事是他们非常认真地对待小丑表演。我的意思是，有像小丑学院这样的地方。哦，我知道。所以我不得不想象这个小丑只是投入了。
Yeah. I would go so hard. Yeah. I feel bad for this woman because it sounds like this dinner party started out nice. She got out her fancy dishes. She provided all the food. Something happened. What was the misstep here?
是的。我会全力以赴。是的。我为这个女人感到难过，因为听起来这个晚宴开始时还不错。她拿出了她精致的餐具。她提供了所有的食物。发生了一些事情。这里的失误是什么？
What was the clown? Well, I know, but how did we get there? I don't know. What's our train of thought? But this whole thing with this clown, like, do they commit? Do they not commit? Right? It's making me think of this interview.
小丑是怎么回事？好吧，我知道，但我们是怎么走到这一步的？我不知道。我们的思路是什么？但关于这个小丑的整件事，就像，他们投入吗？他们不投入吗？对吧？这让我想起了这个采访。
I just saw Jack Black do on Seth Myers. Well, I'll let him explain it. But Jack Black was in an S&L sketch that bombed, but he didn't take his foot off the gas. He just. He went, he fully committed. He did. He said, I only have one gear.
我刚看到杰克·布莱克在塞斯·梅耶斯的节目上做的。好吧，我会让他解释。但杰克·布莱克参加了一个失败的 SNL 小品，但他没有松开油门。他只是。他去了，他完全投入了。他确实。他说，我只有一个档位。
You got to hear this. This is a tangent, but that's what this is making me think of. This talk about dinner parties gone wrong, this kind of vibe. You had a sketch that did not air. that is still incredibly beloved among my cohort from that era, which was written by Amy Poller and Emily Spivey, Boys Night Out.
你得听听这个。这是一个题外话，但这正是这让我想到的。这种关于晚宴出错的谈话，这种氛围。你有一个没有播出的短剧。在那个时代的我的同龄人中仍然非常受欢迎，是由艾米·波勒和艾米丽·斯派维写的，《男生之夜》。
Oh, yeah. Boys Night Out was a guy he was very excited because his wife was going on for the day and he was going to have a Boys Night Out. I pitched it to Amy and Amy wrote it up for me. Yeah.
哦，是的。《男生之夜》是一个家伙，他非常兴奋，因为他的妻子要出去一天，他要过一个“男生之夜”。我把它推销给艾米，艾米为我写了出来。是的。
He spoke for me. And it was just a little song. I was like, I think it would be really fun to come out and sing a song. Boys Night Outta. Boys Night Out. Now I was a little. really rocking and that ticks and run.
他为我说话。这只是一首小歌。我说，我觉得出来唱首歌会很有趣。男生之夜。男生之夜。现在我有点。真的很摇滚，而且节奏很快。
That's what. Talk about it. And then it was like, I'm on it. And she wrote it. God bless her. And I thought it was funny. But then, yeah, in the dress, it really took a dump ski. And it was like, it's out. And I agreed with Lauren.
就是这样。谈谈它。然后就像，我在上面。她写了它。上帝保佑她。我觉得这很有趣。但后来，在彩排中，它真的搞砸了。就像，它出局了。我同意劳伦的看法。
I was like, no, yeah, don't. Let's not do it. I will say, like, it took a dump ski, not. And you never took your foot off the gas. No, I was. We all knew it wasn't going to go to air. We're like, look at Jack trying his hardest. I've always.
我说，不，是的，别。我们别做了。我会说，就像，它搞砸了，不是。而且你从来没有松开过油门。不，我是。我们都知道它不会播出。我们就像，看杰克在尽他最大的努力。我一直。
I've only got one dear. As anyone who knows who knows. See, if Jack Black showed up at your house as a clown, he'd go all in. That's how I pictured this moment at this woman's dinner party. Oh, well, thank you, everybody, for sending in your letters. We hope you enjoy this breakdown of dinner party. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey.
我只有一个档位。任何认识我的人都知道。你看，如果杰克·布莱克以小丑的身份出现在你家，他会全力以赴。这就是我想象中这个女人晚宴上的那一刻。哦，好吧，谢谢大家寄来你们的信。我们希望你们喜欢这次对“晚宴”的解析。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。
We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewere. watch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. I have tears in my eyes because I am so excited. You know what that song means. This time for a dinner party. Oh my gosh. I'm so excited. You and I watched this episode so many times over and over this week. And I'm telling you, I loved it every single time. Angela, my husband Lee, had never seen
我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你做终极的《办公室》重看播客。每周，我们都会解析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是“办公室女士”。我眼里含着泪水，因为我太兴奋了。你知道那首歌意味着什么。这次是晚宴。哦，天哪。我太兴奋了。你和我这周看了很多遍这一集。我告诉你，我每次看都喜欢。安吉拉，我丈夫李，从来没看过
this episode. How is that possible? That is crazy. I got to watch it with a person who's never seen it. I thought he was going to choke. He was laughing so hard, especially during the condo tour. He couldn't catch his breath. Well, my whole family had to watch it over and over. Each one of them washed it with me once. Guys, it is season four, episode 13, written by Gene Stepnitsky and Lee Eisenberg, directed by Paul Feig, arguably, maybe the best episode of the office. Definitely one of the most memorable. Every time Jenna and I are, you know, doing interviews or talking about the show, this is
这一集。这怎么可能？这太疯狂了。我得和一个从没看过的人一起看。我以为他会噎住。他笑得太厉害了，尤其是在公寓参观的时候。他喘不过气来。好吧，我全家都不得不一遍又一遍地看。他们每个人都和我一起看了一次。伙计们，这是第四季第 13 集，由吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格编剧，保罗·费格导演，可以说是《办公室》最好的一集。绝对是最令人难忘的一集之一。每次珍娜和我，你知道，在接受采访或谈论这部剧时，这都是
an episode we are always asked about. I feel so honored that I got to be at that awkward dinner table. What a great lifelong memory. And we have some really special things for you today. Starting with the summary. I'm not reading the summary today, Angela. Oh, no, no, no, no. You know who needs to read the summary.
我们总是被问到的一集。我感到非常荣幸能在那张尴尬的餐桌旁。多么美好的终身记忆。今天我们为你准备了一些非常特别的东西。从总结开始。安吉拉，我今天不读总结。哦，不，不，不，不。你知道谁需要读总结。
The host of the dinner party himself. Mr. Steve Carell. You are cordially invited to Michael and Jan's condo for a last-minute couples-only dinner party. Attendance is limited. We only have six wine glasses. Join Jim and Pam, Angela and Andy,
晚宴的主人本人。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔先生。诚挚邀请您参加迈克尔和简的公寓，参加最后一分钟的仅限情侣的晚宴。出席人数有限。我们只有六个酒杯。加入吉姆和帕姆，安吉拉和安迪，
and eventually Dwight and his former babysitter for an evening of drinks, games, music, candles, Osobuco, and a home tour like no other. Snip snap, snip, snap. Let's get to it. Yeah. Thank you, Steve Corral,
以及最终的德怀特和他的前保姆，度过一个充满饮料、游戏、音乐、蜡烛、炖牛膝和独一无二的家庭参观之夜。剪断，连接，剪断，连接。让我们开始吧。是的。谢谢你，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，
for reading our summary. So, guys, we were a little nervous about this one because it is such a big episode. We wanted to really do a a good job. And there is so much to cover, so Jenna and I reached out to all of the guests of the dinner party and also to our writers and our director, Paul Feig. And everyone is sending in audio clips. Let's get started. Fast fact number one, this episode was written by Gene Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg. I spoke with both of them, Angela. Gene told me that the inspiration for this
阅读我们的总结。所以，伙计们，我们对这一集有点紧张，因为它是一集大制作。我们真的想做得很好。而且有很多内容要涵盖，所以珍娜和我联系了晚宴的所有客人，还有我们的编剧和导演保罗·费格。每个人都发来了音频片段。让我们开始吧。速记事实一，这一集是由吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格编写的。我和他们俩都谈过了，安吉拉。吉恩告诉我，这一集的灵感来源是
episode was the Edward Albee play Who's Afraid of Virginia Wolf. Now, if you guys don't know this play, it is amazing. And it is about a crazy older married couple who invites a younger couple from their work over for a dinner party. And it's just this insane evening. It completely goes off the rails. There's a movie version starring Elizabeth Taylor and Richard Burton that is crazy good. You can check it out. If you liked this episode, you'll like that movie. Here's a little fun fact from Lee Eisenberg. The original working title for this episode was, Who's Afraid of Jan Levinson Gould?
爱德华·阿尔比的戏剧《谁害怕弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫》。现在，如果你们不知道这部戏，它太棒了。它是关于一对疯狂的老年夫妇邀请一对来自他们工作的年轻夫妇来参加晚宴。这是一个疯狂的夜晚。它完全失控了。有一个由伊丽莎白·泰勒和理查德·伯顿主演的电影版本，非常棒。你可以看看。如果你喜欢这一集，你会喜欢那部电影。这是来自李·艾森伯格的一个有趣的事实。这一集的原始工作标题是《谁害怕简·莱文森·古尔德？》
Which makes total sense to me because Jan Levinson Gould really brings it. She scared the bejesus out of me in this episode. There are a few moments where she looks at Pam where I was like, I would not want to be Pam today. For sure. Jean told me that they were assigned this script right before the writers went on their summer hiatus in June of 2007. So guys, we would go on this little hiatus every summer and the writers could go off and write episodes. Normally, writers only got one
这对我来说完全说得通，因为简·莱文森·古尔德真的很有料。她在这一集中把我吓坏了。有几个时刻她看着帕姆，我当时想，我今天可不想成为帕姆。肯定的。吉恩告诉我，他们在 2007 年 6 月编剧们去暑假之前就被分配了这个剧本。所以伙计们，我们每年夏天都会去休假，编剧们可以去写剧集。通常，编剧们只有一个
week to write an episode, but because they were on hiatus, they had three weeks to work on this episode. I mean, they only got paid for one, but they said they couldn't put it down. They just kept adding details and details. They used their whole hiatus to write it. I mean, I think it shows. I don't want to change the whole structure of how we do television. Maybe we should all get three weeks for a script, just saying. So we had a fan question from Megan W. and Meredith H. who want to know what everyone's initial reaction to this episode was when we did the table read. Oh, guys. One of the first people I reached out to was Malora, and she responded immediately. Here is Malora's reaction to getting the script. When I read the dinner party episode, I was
周的时间来写一集，但因为他们在休假，他们有三周的时间来写这一集。我的意思是，他们只拿了一周的钱，但他们说他们放不下。他们只是不断地添加细节和细节。他们用整个假期来写它。我的意思是，我认为这表现出来了。我不想改变我们制作电视的方式。也许我们都应该为剧本争取三周时间，只是说说而已。所以我们有一个来自梅根·W 和梅雷迪思·H 的粉丝问题，他们想知道当我们进行剧本朗读时，每个人对这一集的最初反应是什么。哦，伙计们。我联系的第一个人之一是梅洛拉，她立即回应了。这是梅洛拉对拿到剧本的反应。当我读到晚宴那一集时，我
definitely just blown away. I was on the floor laughing and really felt like it was going to be so much fun. I just couldn't wait to sink my teeth into it. It just felt like, you know, all of the wonderful, unhealthy and completely dysfunctional elements of Jan and Michael kind of coming to a head. And I couldn't really wait to dive in and get going. Angela, Jean told me that during the table read of this, he sweated through his shirt. He said, it started off a little quiet because the episode is pretty dark, but that by the end, when the cop says, not now, Dwight, the whole room just erupted into laughter. And afterwards, Greg Daniels came up to him and Lee and said, this script was perfect. Wow.
绝对被震撼了。我笑得倒在地上，真的觉得这会非常有趣。我简直迫不及待地想深入其中。这感觉就像，你知道，简和迈克尔所有美妙、不健康和完全功能失调的元素都汇聚在一起了。我真的迫不及待地想投入并开始工作。安吉拉，吉恩告诉我，在剧本朗读期间，他的衬衫都被汗湿透了。他说，开始时有点安静，因为这一集相当黑暗，但到最后，当警察说“现在不行，德怀特”时，整个房间都爆发出了笑声。事后，格雷格·丹尼尔斯走到他和李面前说，这个剧本是完美的。哇。
So Gene reminded me that before he and Lee got their jobs on the office, Gene had been working part-time as Harold Ramos's nanny, and Lee was a temp at HBO. And he just said, Greg changed our lives. So hearing from this man who was our mentor telling us we nailed it, it was the highest compliment he ever received as a writer. I bet that means so much to them. You know, Jenna, here's what I remember.
所以吉恩提醒我，在他和李在《办公室》找到工作之前，吉恩一直在兼职做哈罗德·雷米斯的保姆，而李是 HBO 的临时工。他只是说，格雷格改变了我们的生活。所以听到这个作为我们导师的人告诉我们我们做到了，这是他作为编剧收到的最高赞美。我敢打赌这对他们意义重大。你知道，珍娜，这是我记得的。
remember about this table read. I do remember this build. It started and it just took over the room. People were laughing and then laughing and then really laughing. And by the end, that final line of the script, everyone started applauding. And I remember the applause lasted for like a minute. Yeah. It must have felt so amazing for Jean and Lee to see their hard work, just have that kind of adoration. in the moment. Well, get this, guys. I guess the folks at NBC did not love this script. Oh, no!
关于这次剧本朗读。我确实记得这个构建。它开始了，它就接管了整个房间。人们在笑，然后在大笑，然后真的在大笑。到最后，剧本的最后一行，每个人都开始鼓掌。我记得掌声持续了大约一分钟。是的。对于吉恩和李来说，看到他们的辛勤工作在当下得到那种崇拜，一定感觉太棒了。好吧，听着，伙计们。我想 NBC 的人并不喜欢这个剧本。哦，不！
After the table read, Greg had a phone call with NBC. Uh-oh. When we asked Rain Wilson about this episode, he talks about that phone call. Dinner Party, it is one of the top three all-time great office episodes. It's absolutely extraordinary. It's a pretty dark episode. And after the table read, I heard a story from Greg Daniels that the network was like, that's a very dark episode.
剧本朗读后，格雷格和 NBC 通了电话。哦哦。当我们问雷恩·威尔森关于这一集时，他谈到了那个电话。“晚宴”，它是史上最伟大的三集《办公室》之一。它绝对是非凡的。这是一集相当黑暗的剧集。剧本朗读后，我从格雷格·丹尼尔斯那里听到一个故事，说电视网的人说，那是一集非常黑暗的剧集。
And Greg was like, yes, yes, it is. And like, are we sure we want it so dark? And Greg was like, yep. And they were like, okay. And then we proceeded. You know, I feel like if this episode had come earlier in our run, maybe it wouldn't have happened, right? Maybe NBC would have given notes and Greg would have maybe had to sort of pick his battles. But at this point, our show was so established and critically acclaimed and had won awards, I feel like Greg was able to confidently say to them like, yeah, this is the show. This is how it's written and we're going to do it. Jean and Lee told me that they did not do a rewrite on this script. Wow. You guys, all of our episodes, as amazing as they were, would go through separate.
格雷格说，是的，是的，确实如此。他们说，我们确定想要它这么黑暗吗？格雷格说，是的。他们说，好吧。然后我们就继续了。你知道，我觉得如果这一集出现在我们剧集的早期，也许它就不会发生了，对吧？也许 NBC 会给出意见，格雷格可能不得不选择他的战斗。但在这一点上，我们的剧集已经非常成熟并受到评论界的好评，并且赢得了奖项，我觉得格雷格能够自信地对他们说，是的，这就是这部剧。这就是它的写法，我们要这样做。吉恩和李告诉我，他们没有对这个剧本进行重写。哇。你们这些家伙，我们所有的剧集，尽管很棒，都会经历单独的
several rewrites. That's just kind of how a script comes to be. So for this to not have a single rewrite, that is amazing. Yeah. So we had this amazing script. We're all ready to shoot this amazing episode. And then we got shut down because of the writer's strike. Yeah. For four months. We had to wait. It was just a very surreal time because so many shows that shut down, did not come back. They weren't able to survive the strike. And the fact that we were able to come back and we knew we had scripts waiting for us was huge. But it was really important for us as a cast that we stand with our writers and support them. Gene and Lee said it was really surreal because they went from writing this episode, having this table read to picketing their own set. Yeah. And it was so,
几次重写。这就是剧本的诞生方式。所以对于这一集没有进行一次重写，这太神奇了。是的。所以我们有了这个神奇的剧本。我们都准备好拍摄这一集了。然后我们因为编剧罢工而停工了。是的。四个月。我们不得不等待。那是一个非常超现实的时期，因为很多停工的剧集都没有回来。他们没能从罢工中幸存下来。事实上，我们能够回来，而且我们知道有剧本在等着我们，这太重要了。但对于我们演员来说，与我们的编剧站在一起并支持他们非常重要。吉恩和李说这真的很超现实，因为他们从写这一集、进行剧本朗读到在他们自己的片场外抗议。是的。这太
so bizarre, but we shut down. This leads me to fast fact number two. Fast fact number two is that Paul Feig directed this episode, but he almost did not direct this episode. I couldn't even imagine if it wasn't him. I know. I know. Well, when we reached out to him, he told us how this came about. I had been brought on, I directed a lot of episodes of The Office, but in that season I had been given Survivor Man, which I was really excited about and actually am very, very proud of that episode. But I remember reading the script for the dinner party and it was given to some other director. And I was so jealous because I thought, like, if only I could do this episode, this is like everything I want to do. It's so uncomfortable and cringy and hilarious. But another director was assigned to it.
太离奇了，但我们停工了。这引出了我的速记事实二。速记事实二就是保罗·费格导演了这一集，但他差点没导演这一集。我简直无法想象如果不是他。我知道。我知道。好吧，当我们联系他时，他告诉我们这是怎么发生的。我被带进来了，我导演了很多集《办公室》，但在那一季，我被分配了《幸存者》，我对此非常兴奋，实际上我非常、非常为那一集感到自豪。但我记得读到“晚宴”的剧本时，它被分配给了另一位导演。我非常嫉妒，因为我想，如果我能导演这一集就好了，这就像我想做的一切。它太不舒服、太尴尬、太搞笑了。但另一位导演被分配给了它。
But then the writer strike happened. And so it all fell apart because I did Survivor Man. Then the writer strike stopped everything. And so we were off for months and months and months, however long the writer strike went. And my great joy was at the end of that, everything shifted so much of that director who was supposed to do the dinner party wasn't able to. And so it came back around to me. And so I was so excited to do that episode. I just saw it so clearly in my head.
但后来编剧罢工发生了。所以一切都分崩离析了，因为我做了《幸存者》。然后编剧罢工停止了一切。所以我们休息了几个月又几个月，无论编剧罢工持续了多久。我最大的快乐是在那之后，一切都发生了很大的变化，那个本该导演“晚宴”的导演没能做到。所以它又回到了我这里。所以我非常兴奋能导演那一集。我在脑海中非常清晰地看到了它。
and it was just so funny to me. But the crazy thing about that episode was, once we did it, we knew it was so funny, the audience, the loyal office audiences hated it. It was really a very divisive episode because I think it was so uncomfortable and so cringy that people couldn't deal with it. And I remember, like, we were so excited.
对我来说太搞笑了。但那一集疯狂的事情是，一旦我们拍完，我们就知道它太搞笑了，观众，忠实的《办公室》观众讨厌它。这确实是一集非常分裂的剧集，因为我觉得它太不舒服、太尴尬了，人们无法接受。我记得，我们当时非常兴奋。
All of us, all the writers, everybody, we were so excited because we really thought this was kind of like one of the best things the show could do. and we were kind of all bummed out that people were so weird about it. But I think the whole thing was, it was so uncomfortable that the first time you watch it,
我们所有人，所有的编剧，每个人，我们都非常兴奋，因为我们真的认为这就像这部剧能做的最好的事情之一。我们都因为人们对它的奇怪反应而感到沮丧。但我认为整件事是，它太不舒服了，以至于你第一次看它时，
you almost can't handle it. But once you watch it, a second and third and fourth and however many times you watch it, then it becomes fun because you know it's coming, you know it's going to be terrible, and you just can enjoy the cringiness. And so I could not be prouder of that episode.
你几乎无法承受。但一旦你看了第二遍、第三遍、第四遍，无论你看多少遍，它就会变得有趣，因为你知道它要来了，你知道它会很糟糕，你只需要享受那种尴尬。所以我对那一集感到无比自豪。
It's really, you know, I won a DGA directing award for it, which is the only time I'll ever get an award for anything. But I just think it's the funny. thing in the world. I remember the fan response to this episode was not overwhelmingly positive when the show first aired. Yeah, I remember even within my own extended family, they either loved it or they hated it. Yes, very strong reactions. It has grown to be beloved. It was not beloved when it first aired. You know, I don't know who this other director was that was supposed to direct this episode,
真的，你知道，我为此赢得了 DGA 导演奖，这是我唯一一次获得任何奖项。但我只是觉得它是世界上最有趣的事情。我记得当这部剧刚播出时，粉丝对这一集的反应并不是压倒性的积极。是的，我记得即使在我自己的大家庭里，他们要么喜欢它，要么讨厌它。是的，反应非常强烈。它已经成长为备受喜爱。它在刚播出时并不受欢迎。你知道，我不知道这个本该导演这一集的其他导演是谁，
but Gene told me that this person had never directed a single camera comedy ever, that this episode would have been their first one. Oh, my Lord. Now, maybe it was a big time movie person, you know, and they'd just never done half-hour TV before. I am so glad that we got Paul Feig. Yeah. I mean, you don't want the dinner party script to be your first time at single camera comedy.
但吉恩告诉我，这个人从来没有导演过单机位喜剧，这一集将是他们的第一集。哦，我的上帝。现在，也许他是一个大牌电影人，你知道，他们以前从未做过半小时的电视节目。我很高兴我们得到了保罗·费格。是的。我的意思是，你不想让“晚宴”的剧本成为你第一次尝试单机位喜剧。
If I were that person, I wouldn't sleep. Yeah. No. Fast fact number three, Angela, we know that the writer's strike provided us with Paul Fieg. It also provided us with a problem in the form of your giant belly. I was wondering when you're going to bring that up. I'm not the only person bringing up your belly, Angela, because when we asked Paul Fieg about his memories of shooting this episode, he discussed it. Oh, no.
如果我是那个人，我睡不着觉。是的。不。速记事实三，安吉拉，我们知道编剧罢工为我们提供了保罗·费格。它也以你巨大的肚子形式为我们提供了一个问题。我一直在想你什么时候会提起那个。我不是唯一一个提起你肚子的人，安吉拉，因为当我们问保罗·费格关于他拍摄这一集的记忆时，他讨论了它。哦，不。
One of my favorites is how we had to desperately hide Angela's pregnancy during it because she was very late stages. And so you'll notice a lot of her carrying flowers and things in the foreground and then a pillow on her lap when she's sitting on the couch. I think we had her in a big giant overcoat too. So that was fun. It was very challenging, doing special effects with no special effects. So Angela, we also got mail about your belly from Susie S, Alex G. and M.O.
我最喜欢的一点是我们是如何拼命隐藏安吉拉在拍摄期间的怀孕，因为她已经处于怀孕后期。所以你会注意到她经常在前景中拿着花之类的东西，然后当她坐在沙发上时，腿上放着一个枕头。我想我们还让她穿了一件巨大的大衣。所以那很有趣。这非常有挑战性，在没有特效的情况下做特效。所以安吉拉，我们也收到了关于你肚子的邮件，来自苏西·S、亚历克斯·G 和 M.O。
Oh, no, ladies. They want to know how far along were you in your pregnancy? And what kind of meeting was there for hiding Angela's baby bump in this episode? Please tell us everything. Well, ladies, if memory serves me, we filmed this episode in early March. Now, you have to remember, when we did the deposition, I was barely showing. Four months have gone by into my pregnancy. I had my baby early May.
哦，不，女士们。她们想知道你怀孕多久了？在这一集中隐藏安吉拉的孕肚有什么样的会议？请告诉我们一切。好吧，女士们，如果记忆没出错的话，我们在 3 月初拍摄了这一集。现在，你必须记住，当我们做证词时，我几乎看不出来。我怀孕已经四个月了。我在 5 月初生了孩子。
So it was a belly. It was a full-on, a baby. belly. And I do remember poor Paul Fieg, he's the sweetest person coming up to me and being like, hey, Angela, so we're going to have you stand behind the copier. We're going to have you hold this pillow. We're going to have you hold a purse. We're going to have flowers. We're going to have a wall you stand behind. They're like all of these things. There were actual meetings about how to hide my belly. And then when we started filming, I remember tucking behind the copier and Matt Sown, our camera operator saying, I can still see it, Ange.
所以那是一个肚子。那是一个完全的、婴儿的肚子。我确实记得可怜的保罗·费格，他是最甜的人，走过来对我说，嘿，安吉拉，所以我们要让你站在复印机后面。我们要让你拿着这个枕头。我们要让你拿着一个钱包。我们要有花。我们要有一堵墙让你站在后面。他们就像所有这些事情。确实有关于如何隐藏我肚子的会议。然后当我们开始拍摄时，我记得躲在复印机后面，我们的摄像师马特·索恩说，我还能看到它，安吉。
I was like, what? So now there was this new dialogue I had with the camera operators where they'd be like, back it up a little, pivot, pivot, duck, hold it higher. We had this whole language of the belly hide. Am I correct that in that scene when you first enter the condo and Michael and Jan are trying to take your coats, you don't take off your coat because you needed it to hide your belly? Oh, yeah. And my coat was enormous. It's like not a coat I would ever wear.
我当时想，什么？所以现在我和摄像师有了这种新的对话，他们会说，往后退一点，旋转，旋转，蹲下，举高一点。我们有一整套隐藏肚子的语言。我说的对吗，在那个场景中，当你第一次进入公寓，迈克尔和简试图拿走你们的外套时，你没有脱掉你的外套，因为你需要它来隐藏你的肚子？哦，是的。而且我的外套非常大。这不是我会穿的外套。
It was so big. But yeah, I have a lot of track the belly moments for this episode that I can sprinkle in as we go. But we had to get creative. It was a big belly. One day, no belly. Next day, big belly. That's what happened during the writer's strike. Well, guys, those are my fast facts.
它太大了。但是的，我有很多关于这一集的追踪肚子的时刻，我可以在我们进行时穿插进去。但我们必须发挥创造力。那是一个大肚子。有一天，没有肚子。第二天，大肚子。这就是编剧罢工期间发生的事情。好吧，伙计们，这就是我的速记事实。
I think we should take a break and we will be back with a dinner party and more audio clips from our dinner guests. Light your candles. Get your Osobuko going. and we're about to have a dinner party. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you,
我想我们应该休息一下，我们会带着晚宴和更多来自我们晚餐客人的音频片段回来。点上你的蜡烛。开始做你的炖牛膝。我们马上就要举行晚宴了。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，仅仅因为是新的一年，并不意味着你必须成为一个全新的你。但也许你想成为一个负担较轻的你，
a clearer you. Not a totally new you, but maybe like you just want to hone in. You want to refine. Yeah. I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down,
一个更清醒的你。不是一个全新的你，但也许就像你只是想磨练一下。你想精炼。是的。我喜欢那个。精炼。好吧，治疗可以帮助更容易地识别是什么让你感到沉重，
what might be holding you back, You can better understand your relationships, your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things. Mm-hmm. Because those really just add up. Mm-hmm. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, what are big things.
是什么可能在阻碍你，你可以更好地理解你的人际关系、你的动机、你的情绪。我正试图放手，不再为小事而烦恼。嗯。因为那些真的只是加起来。嗯。而且他们会没事的。好吧，你可能需要帮助来识别什么是小事，什么是大事。
Mm-hmm. BetterHelp therapists can help. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy. to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com
嗯。BetterHelp 治疗师可以提供帮助。拥有超过 30,000 名治疗师，BetterHelp 是世界上最大的在线治疗平台，已在全球为超过 500 万人提供服务。BetterHelp 让它变得简单。在线匹配合格的治疗师。注册并在 betterhelp.com 获得 10% 的折扣
slash office ladies. That's better h-elp.com slash office ladies. I'm Emigreed, host of Aspire with Emigreed, a podcast where I sit down with people who don't just dream big, they build big. From culture-shaping voices like Mel Robbins to leaders redefining success on their own terms to gain changing entrepreneurs like Mark Cuban.
/officeladies。那是 better h-elp.com/officeladies。我是艾玛·格里德，《与艾玛·格里德一起渴望》的主持人，这是一个播客，我与那些不仅梦想远大，而且建立远大事业的人坐下来交谈。从像梅尔·罗宾斯这样塑造文化的声音，到以自己的方式重新定义成功的领导者，再到像马克·库班这样改变游戏规则的企业家。
Aspire is about mindset, ambition, and doing the work that actually moves the needle. If you're ready to raise your standards and take charge about the life and career you're building, Aspire is where you start. Follow and listen to Aspire with me, Emma Greed, and Odyssey Podcasts, available wherever you get your podcasts. We are back. We are at the office. It's a Friday night. We're working late. Oh, there's a special assignment from corporate, which we never find out what the special assignment is. Really and truly, how creative did Michael Scott have to get? That he was eight. able to con the whole bullpen. Yeah, everyone's shuffling papers. They're looking at things. What are we doing?
“渴望”是关于心态、雄心和做真正能推动事情发展的实际工作。如果你准备好提高你的标准并掌控你正在建立的生活和职业，那么“渴望”就是你的起点。关注并收听我，艾玛·格里德和 Odyssey Podcasts 的“渴望”，在你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。我们回来了。我们在办公室。这是一个周五晚上。我们工作到很晚。哦，有一个来自公司的特别任务，我们从来不知道特别任务是什么。真的，迈克尔·斯科特必须变得多有创意？他八岁。能够欺骗整个办公室。是的，每个人都在洗牌。他们在看东西。我们在做什么？
What do we think the assignment is? It seems like we're doing stuff. I feel like this is Michael's smartest moment that he came up with a special assignment that everyone believed. Yeah. At 36 seconds, Jenna, is when Jim knows. I believe this is when Jim knows because Michael gets on the phone to corporate and he's like, it's not fair to these people. These people are my friends and I care about them. Like, who talks like that to corporate? I know. Jim knows. But people are grumbling. They're griping and there is a great deleted scene. It's a whole runner with Toby. Toby is sharing that he's so bummed out because he had tickets to Tom Petty. What? Yeah. And Toby had to give them to his ex-wife And her new boyfriend.
我们认为任务是什么？看起来我们在做事情。我觉得这是迈克尔最聪明的时刻，他想出了一个每个人都相信的特别任务。是的。在 36 秒时，珍娜，是吉姆知道的时候。我相信这就是吉姆知道的时候，因为迈克尔给公司打电话，他说，这对这些人不公平。这些人是我的朋友，我关心他们。就像，谁会那样对公司说话？我知道。吉姆知道。但人们在抱怨。他们在发牢骚，有一个很棒的删除场景。这是与托比的一整条线。托比分享说他非常沮丧，因为他有汤姆·佩蒂的票。什么？是的。而且托比不得不把它们给他的前妻和她的新男友。
Oh, no. So, yeah, everyone is kind of like, they're bummed out. Why are they staying so late? And then Michael proudly walks in because he's had this phone call. And he's like, you know what? You don't have to stay late. I told corporate, we're not doing it. Everyone can go home.
哦，不。所以，是的，每个人都有点像，他们很沮丧。他们为什么要待到这么晚？然后迈克尔自豪地走进来，因为他打了这个电话。他说，你知道吗？你们不必待到这么晚。我告诉公司，我们不做了。每个人都可以回家。
And they're like, wow, thank you, Michael. Yeah. And then he turns to Jim and he says, hey, you want to come have dinner at our place tonight? I know you have no plans. Oh, and Jim's like, he got me. Yep, yeah. Well, there's a series of deleted talking heads where people talk about their ideal dinner party,
他们就像，哇，谢谢你，迈克尔。是的。然后他转向吉姆说，嘿，你想今晚来我们家吃晚饭吗？我知道你没有计划。哦，吉姆就像，他抓住了我。是的，是的。好吧，有一系列删除的谈话头，人们谈论他们理想的晚宴，
and there's one by Michael Scott that really cracked me up. Sam, can we play that? My ideal dinner party, easy. Jim Pam, Ryan, the mayor, Barack Obama, Shilohio Jolie Pitt, because at the end of the night, Brad or Angelina would have, have to come and pick them up and I would get to meet them. Shailabeef, because of disturbia, all of the children of the world.
有一个迈克尔·斯科特的谈话头真的让我很开心。萨姆，我们可以播放那个吗？我理想的晚宴，简单。吉姆、帕姆、瑞安、市长、巴拉克·奥巴马、希洛·朱莉·皮特，因为在晚上结束时，布拉德或安吉丽娜会不得不来接他们，我就可以见到他们。希亚·拉博夫，因为《后窗惊魂》，世界上所有的孩子。
Val Kilmer, but he probably wouldn't come. Too famous. Obviously, George Clooney. And Jan, definitely, if there was room. Michael would invite all of the children of the world, Val Kilmer, definitely George Clooney, but only Jan if there was room. Oh, that tells you everything you need to know. Right? And I feel like they deleted that because it was tipping his hand too soon, right?
瓦尔·基尔默，但他可能不会来。太出名了。显然，乔治·克鲁尼。还有简，如果有空间的话，肯定会。迈克尔会邀请世界上所有的孩子，瓦尔·基尔默，绝对是乔治·克鲁尼，但只有在有空间的情况下才邀请简。哦，这告诉你所有你需要知道的事情。对吧？我觉得他们删除了那个，因为它太早暴露了他的意图，对吧？
Well, now we have a very sad talking head from Dwight that ends with just crying. He's so sad. He hasn't been invited. Yeah. I thought Rain was so funny in this talking head. He really made me laugh. Bless his heart. All right, lady. It's time to go to the condo. All right. So Pam and Jim arrived to the condo. It's already awkward.
好吧，现在我们有一个来自德怀特的非常悲伤的谈话头，最后只是哭泣。他太难过了。他没有被邀请。是的。我觉得雷恩在这个谈话头里太搞笑了。他真的让我笑了。保佑他的心。好了，女士。是时候去公寓了。好的。所以帕姆和吉姆到达了公寓。这已经很尴尬了。
And this is going to be a comedy sprint to the end. It's just going to be one joke after the next. Well, it starts with both Michael and Jan trying to hug Jim at the same time. And then I don't know if you noticed, but only Michael hugs Pam. Jan does not even go in for a hug. Oh, I noticed. And then she throws you some serious shade about the wine you, brought. She's like, oh, thank you so much. This will be great to cook with, which you guys know is code for
这将是一场喜剧冲刺到最后。这只是一个接一个的笑话。好吧，它始于迈克尔和简同时试图拥抱吉姆。然后我不知道你是否注意到了，但只有迈克尔拥抱了帕姆。简甚至没有去拥抱。哦，我注意到了。然后她对你带来的酒扔了一些严重的阴影。她就像，哦，非常感谢。这用来做饭会很棒，你们知道这是代码，意思是
thanks for the crappy wine. Exactly. Angela, Gene told me that one of their goals in this episode was that it would just be loaded with a ton of subtle passive aggressive comments and coded language and that this dig at Pam about the wine was the first. Gene also told me that this moment was inspired by the fact that he and Lee were roommates when they first started writing on the show and that Lee Eisenberg is an amazing cook. He referred to him as a gourmand. What? Yeah. And one time, Gene saw Lee cooking with some wine, which was something that Gene did not know you could do. His actual words were, it blew my mind. He's such a dude. Of course you can cook with wine. Well, I guess Lee explained to him that it has to be a cheap wine.
谢谢你带来的烂酒。完全正确。安吉拉，吉恩告诉我，他们在这一集中的目标之一是它应该充满大量的微妙的被动攻击评论和编码语言，而这个对帕姆关于酒的挖苦是第一个。吉恩还告诉我，这一刻的灵感来自于他和李在刚开始写这部剧时是室友，而且李·艾森伯格是一位了不起的厨师。他称他为美食家。什么？是的。有一次，吉恩看到李用一些酒做饭，这是吉恩不知道你可以做的事情。他实际的话是，这让我大吃一惊。他真是个家伙。当然你可以用酒做饭。好吧，我想李向他解释说它必须是一种便宜的酒。
And that always stuck in his head that you cook with cheap wine. And that's why he gave that line to Jan. Well, it's perfect. Babe. Should we take a tour, babe? Yeah, babe. Oh, I'm so sorry about this horrendous carpet. We're a work in progress.
这总是印在他的脑海里，你用便宜的酒做饭。这就是为什么他把那句台词给了简。好吧，这很完美。宝贝。我们去参观一下吗，宝贝？是的，宝贝。哦，我很抱歉这可怕的地毯。我们是一个正在进行的工作。
I call this the mask wall, babe. Oh, we watch this episode a lot, but it's so good. This home tour really kicks off all of the Jan and Michael dynamics in this episode. and when we asked John Krasinski about his memories of this episode, he talked about this scene of Jim and Pam arriving and then starting the tour. That episode was without a doubt one of my favorite to ever shoot because there was this incredible energy on set, this idea that we were finally getting to pull the curtain back
我称这为面具墙，宝贝。哦，我们看了很多遍这一集，但它太好了。这次家庭参观真的开启了这一集中所有的简和迈克尔的动态。当我们问约翰·卡拉辛斯基关于这一集的记忆时，他谈到了吉姆和帕姆到达然后开始参观的场景。那一集毫无疑问是我拍摄过的最喜欢的剧集之一，因为片场有一种令人难以置信的能量，这种想法是我们终于要拉开窗帘了
on the world of Michael Scott. And I think that for me, I was already almost laughing in every scene because of how Steve was playing his character, there was this unbelievable beaming of pride and joy to have these two people finally in his home after what I imagine to be a lifetime of hoping and wishing that it could be possible one day. And here they were. And not only were they in his home, he was able to give them a tour. And then the battling dichotomy of Michael's excitement and Jan's sort of weighty judgment
在迈克尔·斯科特的世界里。而且我认为对我来说，我已经在每个场景中几乎都在笑，因为史蒂夫扮演他的角色的方式，有一种令人难以置信的自豪和快乐的光芒，让这两个人终于在他的家里，在我想象中，经过一生的希望和祈祷，有一天这可能成为可能。他们就在这里。而且他们不仅在他的家里，他还能给他们参观。然后迈克尔的兴奋和简对他的房子和他的兴奋的某种沉重的判断的战斗二分法
of his house and his excitement was all loaded into every scene. It's so true. So true. So well said, JK. We got a fan question, Angela, from Cameron W. Linda M. and Monica J. Did you guys actually film in someone's house? Oh, yeah. There was a man that owned this condo.
加载到每个场景中。太真实了。太真实了。说得太好了，JK。我们有一个粉丝问题，安吉拉，来自卡梅伦·W、琳达·M 和莫妮卡·J。你们真的在别人的房子里拍摄吗？哦，是的。有一个人拥有这个公寓。
Yeah. It was a condo in Woodland Hills, California. And I remember they told me they had to take. out all of that man's furniture and repaint his walls. And then they had to put it all back the way he had it. And that blew my mind. I know. In the deposition DVD commentary, Ed talked about this for a minute. He said when they filmed in the garage, this man's belongings, there were some of them that they just shoved all into one corner. And they were like, what is this guy about? Because guess what he had? What? He had all of these professional.
是的。那是加利福尼亚州伍德兰希尔斯的一套公寓。我记得他们告诉我，他们必须把那个男人的所有家具都搬走，重新粉刷墙壁。然后他们还得把一切恢复原样。这让我大吃一惊。我知道。在证词DVD评论中，埃德谈到了这一点。他说当他们在车库拍摄时，这个男人的物品，有些被他们一股脑儿塞进了一个角落。他们当时就在想，这家伙到底是干什么的？因为你猜他有什么？什么？他有所有这些专业的。
ping pong player posters. What? Yes. And they had just had all this ping pong in the deposition. So they were like, oh my gosh. And they recognized some of the names because of Dwight's talking head. And he said, in addition to all the professional ping pong posters, he had a professional ping pong table that was folded up and sort of wedged in the corner. Wow. So this guy obviously was a ping pong enthusiast. We know that. Maybe he was a amateur uprising professional ping pong player. Maybe he was a champion. We don't know. We don't know. But yes, he had to move all of his stuff out and cram a bunch of stuff into the corner of the garage. And then we had to put it all back for him. Well, we asked Paul Figue about designing the condo for Michael and Jan. And here is what he had to say. For Michael and Jan's condo, I had the benefit of being the person, the director who got to do Office Olympics, which was where we established. Michael and Jan's condo when he bought it. And so, you know, found this very kind of stark, normal cookie cutter kind of condo that he would have with very stark white walls and all that. And that was really fun.
乒乓球运动员海报。什么？是的。他们在证词中提到了所有这些乒乓球。所以他们当时就在想，天哪。而且因为德怀特的谈话头，他们认出了一些名字。他说，除了所有专业的乒乓球海报，他还有一张专业的乒乓球桌，折叠起来塞在角落里。哇。所以这家伙显然是个乒乓球爱好者。我们知道这一点。也许他是个业余的、想成为职业的乒乓球选手。也许他是个冠军。我们不知道。我们不知道。但确实，他不得不把所有的东西都搬出去，把一堆东西塞进车库的角落。然后我们还得为他把一切都放回去。好吧，我们问了保罗·费格关于为迈克尔和简设计公寓的事。这是他要说的。对于迈克尔和简的公寓，我有幸作为导演来负责《办公室奥运会》，也就是我们在那里确定了迈克尔和简买下公寓后的样子。所以，你知道，找到了这种非常刻板、普通、千篇一律的公寓，他会有非常刺眼的白墙之类的。那真的很有趣。
So when I was lucky enough to get to do this episode and go back to there, the whole concept of what Jan would have done with that place was really fun to play with. And I remember Lee and Gene and I got really hung up on the idea that she had a warhol. I think they even put it into the script, but that she had done like a Warhol-esque print of herself.
所以当我幸运地能做这一集并回到那里时，简会对那个地方做什么的整个概念真的很有趣。我记得李、吉恩和我对她有一个沃霍尔作品的想法非常着迷。我想他们甚至把它写进了剧本，但她做了一幅类似沃霍尔风格的自己的画像。
Would you only see briefly when they're in the hallway, I think when Jim and Pam first arrive, and you see it in the stairwell when they go up to the infamous candle room. And it's like this quad warhol style picture of Jan. But I just love the idea that we had to show off how Jan had fixed up the place, but also the idea that Jan had done it, even though she tried to warm it up, It was kind of very cold.
我想当吉姆和帕姆刚到达时，你在走廊里只能短暂地看到它，当你上楼去那个臭名昭著的蜡烛房时，你在楼梯间也能看到它。那是一幅简的四格沃霍尔风格的画。但我只是喜欢这个想法，我们必须展示简是如何装饰这个地方的，但也喜欢这个想法，即使她试图让它变得温馨，它仍然非常冷清。
So we were hung up on the idea of like really, like, dark gray walls and what art you would have put up. And I was very, very hung up on the idea of them putting up a, that Jan put up a kimono on the wall, which I had seen somewhere and thought, oh, that's kind of a cool decoration, but it's also not terribly warm at the same time. And so that made me laugh. I have to add another little tidbit, Angela, is that I guess they put up a bunch of photos. You can't really tell when you're watching, but they are all photos of Jan and other men. There are no photos of Jan and Michael.
所以我们对深灰色的墙壁以及你会挂什么艺术品这个想法非常着迷。我非常非常执着于他们挂上一件和服的想法，我曾在某处看到过，觉得，哦，那是一种很酷的装饰，但同时它也不是特别温馨。这让我笑了。我必须再补充一个小花絮，安吉拉，我想他们挂了一堆照片。你看的时候其实看不出来，但它们都是简和其他男人的照片。没有简和迈克尔的照片。
And then there's a lot of photos I remember of just Jan by herself. Yes, like in a frame. Like she has made it the Jan shrine. But I love that she has given it her touch, but it's in no way homie. No, it's just really kind of cold. And Michael has no space that is his own. except maybe where all of his rejected furniture items have gone into the garage. Yeah, they take Pam and Jim on this tour,
还有很多我记得的照片，只是简一个人。是的，在相框里。就像她把它变成了简的圣坛。但我喜欢她赋予了它自己的风格，但它一点也不像个家。不，它真的有点冷清。迈克尔没有任何属于他自己的空间，除了可能他所有被拒绝的家具都进了车库。是的，他们带帕姆和吉姆参观，
and we learn that Jan has both an office space and a workspace because she can't create in her office space. And her desk in her office space look like no one had ever sat there. It's so sparse. Oh, at three minutes, 32 seconds, you can see that her desk chair still has the plastic cover on the arms. Oh, my gosh, fantastic. That was a little detail that Paul Fieg had. He thought that would be funny.
我们了解到简既有办公空间又有工作空间，因为她在办公空间里无法创作。她在办公空间的桌子看起来就像从来没有人坐过一样。太稀疏了。哦，在3分32秒，你可以看到她的办公椅扶手上还有塑料套。天哪，太棒了。那是保罗·费格的一个小细节。他觉得那会很有趣。
So he made them leave it on. That's great. They put so much thought into every little nook and cranny of that condo. Should we talk about the candle room? Yes. I can't imagine what that smelled like. It must have been so strong. Oh, lady.
所以他让他们留着它。太棒了。他们对那间公寓的每一个角落都倾注了如此多的心血。我们应该谈谈蜡烛房吗？是的。我无法想象那是什么味道。一定非常浓烈。哦，天哪。
We got a lot of mail about it. From Ross C, Sierra S, Allie E, and Emily D. Did the candle room actually smell like? candles. Oh yeah. It was a room full of multiple scented candles. Well, I didn't have to go in the candle room and thank goodness because I was pregnant and so sensitive to smell. I probably would have been like, but Paul Feig spoke about the candle room and here's the audio clip. The candle room. We just knew that we wanted the candle room to be insane. And the big thing was like when you're in there, it smelled crazy. And it was like, how do we do that?
我们收到了很多关于它的邮件。来自罗斯·C、塞拉·S、艾莉·E和艾米丽·D。蜡烛房真的闻起来像蜡烛吗？哦，是的。那是一个装满了多种香氛蜡烛的房间。好吧，我不需要去蜡烛房，谢天谢地，因为我当时怀孕了，对气味非常敏感。我可能会说，但保罗·费格谈到了蜡烛房，这是音频片段。蜡烛房。我们只是知道我们想让蜡烛房变得疯狂。最重要的是，当你身处其中时，味道太疯狂了。就像，我们该怎么做呢？
How do we put that across to an audience? Because one thing, an audience can't take in. Two things, they can't take in the temperature of what's happening and they can't take in the smell of what's happening. And so that's where you have that shot of John Krasinski, kind of like looking out the door and you're like, ooh, like you can't breathe because you just know it just stinks in there. But I really just loved how dense and terrible we made that room. I loved John's look to camera when he was gasping for air. It was so believable and funny.
我们该如何向观众传达这一点？因为有一件事，观众无法感知。两件事，他们无法感知正在发生的事情的温度，也无法感知正在发生的事情的气味。所以这就是为什么会有约翰·卡拉辛斯基那个镜头，他从门口往外看，你会觉得，噢，就像你无法呼吸，因为你知道里面简直臭死了。但我真的很喜欢我们把那个房间做得如此密集和糟糕。我喜欢约翰对着镜头喘不过气来的表情。那太真实、太搞笑了。
And I don't think that was probably an easy thing to convey, but he did it so well. So well. John and I talked with Paul before we shot that scene. And he said, I want it to look like you guys are doing that thing when you walk into a stinky public restroom. And you've taken like a deep breath before you walk in. You're trying to hold it for as long as you can. And then you need air. So you're just trying to take in the smallest amount of air that will get you through. Yeah. So that's what we were trying to do in that scene. Well, now they move into the master bedroom. Oh, my gosh, there are so many delicious moments in this. I do not know how you guys got through this. Well, I'm going to say that a lot through this episode because there are scenes that were just the four of you that are some of the funniest scenes I've ever seen.
而且我不认为这可能是一件容易传达的事情，但他做得太好了。太好了。约翰和我在这场戏拍摄前和保罗谈过。他说，我希望看起来就像你们走进一个臭气熏天的公共厕所时那样。你在走进去之前深吸了一口气。你试图尽可能长时间地屏住呼吸。然后你需要空气。所以你只是试图吸入最少量的空气来让你撑过去。是的。所以这就是我们在那场戏中试图做的。好吧，现在他们搬进了主卧室。天哪，这里面有太多精彩的时刻了。我不知道你们是怎么熬过来的。好吧，在这一集中我会经常这么说，因为有些场景只有你们四个人，是我见过最有趣的场景。
And I don't know how you got through this one. This is the scene where for the longest time, there's just a camera on a tripod pointed at the bed. Yeah. which Jim and Pam clock immediately, and so does the audience. And then Jan says, Michael, I told you to put that away. And then she swats him on the butt. It's so uncomfortable. She swats him on the butt.
我不知道你是怎么熬过这一关的。这是那场戏，很长一段时间里，只有一个放在三脚架上的摄像机对着床。是的，吉姆和帕姆立刻注意到了，观众也注意到了。然后简说，迈克尔，我让你把它收起来。然后她拍了他的屁股。太尴尬了。她拍了他的屁股。
Yeah. And then we learned that Michael sleeps on a bench at the foot of the bed. And Angela, I can't even tell you how hard we laughed every time Steve Correll curled up on that bench. When he was like, no, I fit. Look, it's actually pretty comfortable. And he just curls up like a baby on it. Well, Paul shared with us the inspiration behind the bench. And it's so great.
是的。然后我们了解到迈克尔睡在床尾的长凳上。安吉拉，我甚至无法告诉你，每次史蒂夫·卡瑞尔蜷缩在那张长凳上时，我们笑得有多厉害。当他说，不，我能睡下。看，其实挺舒服的。然后他就蜷缩得像个婴儿一样。好吧，保罗和我们分享了长凳背后的灵感。太棒了。
Here it is. So the whole thing with Michael and Jan and that weird bench that he sleeps on to the end of the bed came from when I was working as a script reader in the early 80s for a Hollywood, big Hollywood producer. and I befriended this woman who worked in his company. And at one point, we were hanging out, and we went by her house to pick something up. And I went into there, and they had this open bedroom plan. And I looked, and there was this giant bed, like a king-sized bed. But the next to the bed was this little tiny cot. And I remember saying, like, oh, what's that?
就是这样。所以迈克尔和简以及他睡在床尾的那张奇怪的长凳的整个事情，源于我在80年代初为一个好莱坞大制片人做剧本审稿人时。我结识了在他公司工作的一位女士。有一次，我们在一起玩，我们顺路去了她家拿东西。我进去了，他们有一个开放式的卧室布局。我看了看，那里有一张巨大的床，像特大号床。但在床旁边有一张小小的行军床。我记得我说，哦，那是什么？
And she got very serious. And she said, like, look, when you get in a relationship, you have to make sure that you're able to be intimate with somebody and share things with them. And what it turned out was that once they were done with their time together in bed, she had to roll off onto this cot and sleep by herself because this guy couldn't handle having anybody else in his bed with him.
她变得非常严肃。她说，听着，当你进入一段关系时，你必须确保你能和某人亲密并与他们分享事物。结果是，一旦他们在一起的时间结束，她就得滚到这张行军床上独自睡觉，因为这家伙无法忍受床上还有别人。
And I just thought that was the saddest thing I've ever seen in my life. And so I remember when we were scouting that location and there was that little stool at the... end or that bench at the end of the bed. I can't remember if it was in the script or if we took it and ran with it. But I remember saying to Lee and Gene, like, we had, I told them that story. I said, like, how funny, we have to have this thing where Michael can't sleep in the bed. And so that's what we did. And I just remember when we were shooting it, it made me laugh so much because, you know, the way that Steve Carell would curl up on that bench. And my whole thing
我当时觉得那是我一生中见过的最悲伤的事情。所以我记得当我们勘察那个地点时，床尾有那个小凳子或长凳。我不记得是在剧本里还是我们拿来用了。但我记得我对李和吉恩说，我告诉了他们那个故事。我说，多有趣啊，我们必须有这个情节，迈克尔不能睡在床上。所以我们就这么做了。我只记得我们在拍摄时，它让我笑得太厉害了，因为，你知道，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔蜷缩在那张长凳上的方式。而我的全部想法
was like, okay, we got to hang on this as long as we can. And so. You know, we have Jan going like, oh, he fits perfectly. Ha, ha, ha. And I just tried to get every last frame out of everybody just staring at Michael on this bench. And it's silent and it's just completely uncomfortable. And it makes me laugh still to this day. Now, lady, that clip suggests that maybe this was the condo guy's bed and bench. because he said when they scouted the location, they saw the bench, or maybe just a bench, and then we
就是，好吧，我们得尽可能长时间地保持这个镜头。所以。你知道，我们有简说，哦，他完全睡得下。哈哈哈哈。我只是试图从每个人盯着迈克尔在长凳上的镜头中榨出最后一帧。它是沉默的，完全尴尬的。直到今天它仍然让我发笑。现在，女士，那个片段暗示这可能是公寓主人的床和长凳。因为他说当他们勘察地点时，他们看到了长凳，或者只是一个长凳，然后我们
recreated it. But I have a bench at the end of my bed. No one sleeps on it. But this is a very popular thing. I have an upholstered bench at the foot of my bed as well. It's where I like sort of lay my robe at night. You know, I like kick off my slippers. I put my robe on the bench.
重新创造了它。但我床尾也有一个长凳。没人睡在上面。但这很流行。我床尾也有一张软垫长凳。那是我晚上放睡袍的地方。你知道，我喜欢踢掉拖鞋。我把睡袍放在长凳上。
Yeah. And it's all there for me in the morning. My bench could not fit a grown man. It's a tiny little bench. I actually really looked at that bench and I was like, oh, they found a wide bench. That's a substantial bench. Yes, exactly. It's just big enough that you believe it, but still small enough that it's just so sad.
是的。早上它就在那里等着我。我的长凳可睡不下一个成年男人。那是一个很小的长凳。我其实仔细看了那个长凳，我在想，哦，他们找了一个宽长凳。那是一个结实的长凳。是的，完全正确。它刚好大到让你相信它，但又小到让人觉得太悲伤了。
Yeah. And also, just again, Michael has no space in his own home. She has both guest rooms she's using. And now he doesn't even get to sleep in his bed. It's so sad. It's tragic. And now I've got a fun fact. This scene of the bedroom tour specifically, this scene is John McCain's favorite scene from the office.
是的。而且，再次强调，迈克尔在自己家里没有任何空间。她用了两个客房。现在他甚至不能睡在自己的床上。太悲伤了。这太悲剧了。现在我有一个有趣的事实。卧室参观的这一幕，具体来说，这一幕是约翰·麦凯恩在《办公室》中最喜欢的场景。
And I can tell you why. Yeah, how do you know that? That's such a random tidbit to know. B.J. Novak was at a dinner party with John McCain. I would love to hear that story, how that came about. That's fascinating to me. That's very on brand, though, for B.J. BJ finds himself in these eclectic groups of people all the time.
我可以告诉你为什么。是的，你怎么知道的？这是一个如此随机的琐事。B.J.诺瓦克和约翰·麦凯恩参加了一个晚宴。我很想听听那个故事，它是怎么发生的。这对我来说太迷人了。不过，这对B.J.来说很符合他的风格。BJ总是发现自己身处这些不拘一格的人群中。
So he's at a dinner party. John McCain's there. Yeah, you want to be BJ's plus one to a dinner party because he's going to take you to a cool group. Yeah. He was at this dinner party and someone walked up to him and said, John McCain is a huge fan of the office. Would you like me to make an introduction? Now, I've experienced this too with politicians.
所以他在参加一个晚宴。约翰·麦凯恩也在那里。是的，你想成为BJ参加晚宴的加一，因为他会带你去一个很酷的群体。是的。他在这个晚宴上，有人走过来对他说，约翰·麦凯恩是《办公室》的超级粉丝。你想让我为你介绍一下吗？现在，我也经历过这种情况，和政客们。
A lot of times politicians, they have a person whose job it is to whisper things in their ears that are really specific about the other guests at a party because they vetted everyone at the party so that when the politician meets you, they can say something really specific and personal. It's like the scene you guys in Devil Wears Prada, right? Anne Hathaway's next to Merrill Street. They're at that big shindig in Paris,
很多时候，政客们，他们有一个专门负责在他们耳边低语的人，说一些关于聚会上其他客人的非常具体的事情，因为他们审查了聚会上的每个人，所以当政客见到你时，他们可以说一些非常具体和私人的事情。就像你们在《穿普拉达的女王》里的那一幕，对吧？安妮·海瑟薇在梅丽尔·斯特里普旁边。他们在巴黎参加那个大型聚会，
and she's telling her every little person that walks up, some little tidbit. Yes. So BJ was like, oh, he's probably been told, I work on this show called The Office and yada yada. So BJ was like, I'm going to put him to the test. And I'm going to ask him specifically, John McCain, tell me one of your favorite scenes from the office. BJ.
她告诉她每一个走过来的人，一些小花絮。是的。所以BJ当时想，哦，他可能被告知了，我在这个叫《办公室》的节目工作，等等等等。所以BJ当时想，我要考验他一下。我要专门问他，约翰·麦凯恩，告诉我一个你在《办公室》中最喜欢的场景。BJ。
Right? Oh, my gosh. Okay. So when he met him, he did it. He said, what's one of your favorite scenes? And John McCain said, I love that scene in the dinner party when they're given the house. tour and they walk into the bedroom and the video cameras up in the background and the bench. And he just went on and on with such great detail that BJ knew, oh, this is for real.
对吧？天哪。好吧。所以当他见到他时，他真的这么做了。他说，你最喜欢的场景之一是什么？约翰·麦凯恩说，我喜欢《晚宴》里他们参观房子，走进卧室，背景里有摄像机，还有那张长凳的场景。他滔滔不绝地说了那么多很棒的细节，BJ就知道，哦，这是真的。
This guy does love the office. That's so wild. It's so specific. Yeah. It's such a specific scene. It was. Well, he picked a good episode and he picked a good scene because when I was rewatching this with my husband Lee, this was the scene where I thought we were going to have to pause because he
这家伙确实喜欢《办公室》。太疯狂了。太具体了。是的。这是一个非常具体的场景。确实是。好吧，他选了一集好剧，也选了一个好场景，因为当我跟我丈夫李重温这一集时，这是我以为我们不得不暂停的场景，因为他
couldn't catch his breath. He was, like, laughing so hard. All right. Well, speaking of having to, like, pause to catch your breath because you're laughing so hard, Jenna, up next is the scene with the tiny TV. Oh, my God. The tiny plasma TV that only comes out two inches from the wall. There are two times when I laughed so hard on our show that I thought I wasn't going to ever recover. this was one of them. Tears streaming down our face. We had a fan question from Maddie S, Paula T, Kennedy H. How many takes did you guys have to do when Michael was showing off his plasma TV?
喘不过气来。他笑得太厉害了。好吧，说到因为笑得太厉害而不得不暂停，珍娜，接下来是那个小电视的场景。哦，天哪。那个离墙只有两英寸的等离子小电视。有两次我在我们的节目中笑得太厉害，以为我永远也恢复不过来了。这是其中之一。泪流满面。我们有一个来自马迪·S、保拉·T、肯尼迪·H的粉丝提问。当迈克尔炫耀他的等离子电视时，你们拍了多少次？
Guys, John Krasinski talks about this. I'm going to turn it over to him. When we got to the moment with the television, I think there was an energy in the room that was overwhelming. I was already quaking with laughter. It wouldn't have taken much for me to laugh and then throw in maybe one of my favorite jokes in the entire show.
伙计们，约翰·卡拉辛斯基谈到了这一点。我要把它交给他。当我们拍到电视那一刻时，我觉得房间里有一种令人难以抗拒的能量。我已经笑得发抖了。我不需要太多努力就能笑出来，然后加入可能是整个节目中我最喜欢的笑话之一。
And I remember at the table read laughing, but then to see Steve again with that beaming face of pride just turn to us and say, you won't believe what I have. And also look what it can do when company comes over, I can just do this. And I'm pretty sure that the distance between the TV and the wall was like an inch and a half. And he was so proud that it comes out to watch TV in the comfort of your own home.
我记得在剧本朗读时笑过，但再次看到史蒂夫那张充满自豪的脸转向我们说，你不会相信我有什么。还有看看当客人来时它能做什么，我可以这样做。而且我很确定电视和墙之间的距离大概是一英寸半。他非常自豪，它能出来让你在自己家里舒适地看电视。
And then you push it back a good inch and a half to hide it away when company comes. Luckily, the outtakes are out there in the world. And so you can see, I mean, Jenna can tell you, but I think that it took probably 19 or 20 takes before I was even able to stand up vertically in that scene without doubling over. And again, as I've always said, I'm a cry or laugher. So when I laugh that hard, my entire face turns red with tears and the pressure that's filling in my face for trying not to laugh and to no avail. I don't know why I even try not to laugh. I should just let it out and then my face wouldn't turn beat red in every scene. That is without a doubt one of my favorite scenes and I will cherish that memory for the rest of my career.
然后当客人来时，你把它推回去一英寸半把它藏起来。幸运的是，花絮在世界上流传。所以你可以看到，我的意思是，珍娜可以告诉你，但我认为大概拍了19或20次，我才能在那场戏中垂直站立而不弯腰。而且，正如我一直说的，我是那种笑到哭的人。所以当我笑得那么厉害时，我的整张脸因为试图不笑而充血，泪水和压力填满了我的脸，但无济于事。我不知道为什么我还要试图不笑。我应该直接笑出来，这样我的脸就不会在每一场戏里都变得通红。毫无疑问，这是我最喜欢的场景之一，我将在我职业生涯的余下时间里珍惜那段记忆。
You can hear him losing it just retelling it, you know? Yes. Well, Jenna, one of my daughter's favorite things since we've been doing Office Ladies is watching the bloopers. My daughter, Isabel, absolutely loves them. She watches them over and over. I think it's so fun for her to see you and I laughing and these people that she's known, you know, since she was born, cracking up. So she actually helped me gather all the bloopers for this episode. She knew right where they were. She even knew time codes, Jenna. I love it. You're passing along the love of time codes to Isabel. I am. So I feel like we have to hear the blooper of this scene because it's so. wonderful. Sam, can you play that? I guess what surround sound means is that right over here, Chowell. Two speakers. Damn. We have two speakers. What?
你可以听到他在重述时笑得不行，你知道吗？是的。好吧，珍娜，自从我们做《办公室女士》以来，我女儿最喜欢的事情之一就是看花絮。我女儿伊莎贝尔绝对喜欢它们。她一遍又一遍地看。我觉得看到你和我大笑，还有她从出生就认识的这些人笑得前仰后合，对她来说太有趣了。所以她实际上帮我收集了这一集的所有花絮。她知道它们在哪里。她甚至知道时间码，珍娜。我喜欢它。你正在把对时间码的热爱传递给伊莎贝尔。我是。所以我感觉我们必须听听这一幕的花絮，因为它太美妙了。萨姆，你能播放一下吗？我猜环绕声的意思是就在这里，乔威尔。两个扬声器。该死。我们有两个扬声器。什么？
Honey? Oh, Jesus. This is terrible. We'll never finish this episode. Check this out. Foles. Lady, it makes me a lot. It makes me laugh just hearing it. It makes me crack up. Ladies, Steve did a whole runner where they just let him go with this TV.
亲爱的？哦，天哪。这太糟糕了。我们永远也拍不完这一集。看看这个。福尔斯。女士，这让我笑。光是听到它就让我发笑。这让我笑得前仰后合。女士们，史蒂夫做了一整段即兴表演，他们只是让他带着这台电视发挥。
Oh, man. And he tries to explain that the TV has surround sound. And what he means by that is that the screen is surrounded by a speaker. The whole thing was, you've gone to someone's house when they've just gotten their new TV system with their new sound speakers. and they're so excited to show it off. Maybe they even like play part of a movie for you, right? Yes. That was the inspiration for this.
哦，天哪。他试图解释电视有环绕声。他的意思是屏幕被一个扬声器环绕。整件事就是，你去过某人家里，当他们刚买了带新音响系统的新电视时。他们非常兴奋地炫耀它。也许他们甚至为你播放电影的一部分，对吧？是的。这就是灵感来源。
And so Steve was going to bring that energy of like we were sitting in a professionally done home theater, right? Yes. But instead he's just talking about this tiny TV, which by the way is not even a Plasma TV. It's just a flat screen TV, but it keeps referring to it as a Plasma TV. Oh my God. Jenna, do you know what? I love is that how this is still a joke with the cast. So a few years ago, you guys, we've talked about this before. We have a cast text thread where we will text and check in, say hello, little clips,
所以史蒂夫要带来那种能量，就像我们坐在专业制作的家庭影院里一样，对吧？是的。但相反，他只是在谈论这台小电视，顺便说一句，它甚至不是等离子电视。它只是一台平板电视，但他一直称它为等离子电视。哦，天哪。珍娜，你知道吗？我喜欢的是，这仍然是演员们的一个笑话。所以几年前，你们，我们之前谈过这个。我们有一个演员群聊，我们会发短信、打招呼、问候，发一些小片段，
pictures of our kids. Creed usually sings us a song at Christmas and he'll text us, you know, him at home with his like elf hat on. And Jenna sent a photo to all of us. You were on a job and you walked in to like a little dressing room they had for you. And there was the tiny, TV mounted on the wall, Jenna, and you sent us a picture and we all started cracking up. Yes, I walked into this dressing room and I thought to myself, you could hold this in your hand. Why have they mounted it on the wall? It was so reminiscent of the dinner party episode. I was so excited to send that text and people were loving it. It will never get old to me. That scene. I can watch it and watch it and watch it. But there are so many things in this
我们孩子的照片。克里德通常在圣诞节给我们唱一首歌，他会发短信给我们，你知道，他在家戴着精灵帽的样子。珍娜发了一张照片给我们所有人。你在工作，你走进他们为你准备的一个小更衣室。墙上挂着那台小电视，珍娜，你发了一张照片，我们都笑得前仰后合。是的，我走进那个更衣室，心想，你可以把它拿在手里。为什么要把它挂在墙上？这太让人想起《晚宴》那一集了。我很高兴发了那条短信，大家都很喜欢。对我来说，那一幕永远不会过时。我可以看它，看它，再看它。但这一集中有很多东西在第二次观看时让我发笑，珍娜。而且我也记得拍摄那天，因为我坐在它旁边，迈克尔做的那张破烂的边桌。它看起来是桌子里最悲伤的。他对此感到非常自豪。它看起来像废木头。就像如果你有一箱柴火，他用那个箱子做了这张桌子。对话也让我笑得前仰后合。吉姆说，那是栗木吗？他说，我想要么是松木，要么是北欧樱桃木。我当时想，什么？安吉拉，是你到达这个晚宴的时候了。
living room that made me laugh on a second watch, Jenna. And I also remembered it the day we were filming because I was seated by it, that janky side table that Michael made. It is the saddest looking table. And he's so proud of it. It looks like scrapwood. Like if you got a crate of firewood that he used the crate to make the table. And the dialogue cracked me up too. Jim is like, is that chestnut? And he's like, I think it's either. or Pine or Nordic Cherry. I was like, what? Angela, it's time for you to arrive at this dinner party.
哦，安迪和安吉拉。我们来了。我们有一个来自海莉·M的粉丝提问。安吉拉，当迈克尔过来拥抱你，而你拒绝时，你开始笑场了吗？是的。是的，我几乎，就像约翰说的，我走进那个房间看到一切的那一刻，就在我们开始那些场景的那一刻，我已经
Oh, Andy and Angela. Here we come. We had a fan question from Haley M. Angela, are you starting to break when Michael goes in for the hug, which you refuse? Yes. Yes. I pretty much, like John said, the minute I walked in that room and saw everything, just the minute we started those scenes, I was already.
被逗乐了，从那以后的一切都只是我在努力不笑。我在6分34秒有一个有趣的发现。当安迪脱下外套时，外套下面他穿着一件高领毛衣，外面套着一件衬衫，脖子上还系着一件毛衣。哦，是的，他处于典型的预科生模式。这是我们的编剧吉恩想出的一个点子。他只是觉得让一个脖子上系着毛衣的人脱下外套会非常非常有趣。
tickled and everything from then on was just me trying not to laugh. I have a fun catch at six minutes 34 seconds. When Andy takes off his coat, underneath his coat, he is wearing a turtleneck with a shirt over it and then a sweater tied around his neck. Oh yeah, he's in prime preppy mode. This was a bit that Jean, our writer, came up with. He just thought it would be really, really funny. to have a person who has tied a sweater around their neck, take their coat off.
是的，他们已经在下面准备好了。好吧，你知道，我说过当我们要藏肚子时会告诉你们。这一集里到处都在发生，但我最喜欢的是这束巨大的花。那是为了藏我的肚子。是的。我的肚子就是那么大。看看那束花。他们不得不把花束做得那么大，因为它的目的是让安迪给他的女主人
Yeah, they had that ready to go underneath. Well, you know, I said I would let you guys know when we had some belly hiding. It's happening all through the episode, but one of my favorites is this giant bouquet of flowers. That was to hide my belly. Yes. That's how big my belly is. Look at that bouquet of flowers. They had to make the bouquet that big because the point of it was for Andy to give his hostess
送些花，但它们之所以那么大是因为它们是用来藏肚子的。如果你们回去重看，这里也有一个很棒的花絮，但我有一个想指出来的小发现。是什么？在6分44秒，我站在简旁边，当时安迪正在做那个金枪鱼，金枪鱼，我打赌你吃很多金枪鱼，吃很多金枪鱼，那整段戏。是的。我只是，作为一名演员，我决定做的我自己的小准备就是我盯着简的胸部。我的意思是，我的视线和它们齐平。她穿着高跟鞋。她比我高。它们就在那里。我决定给她一个轻蔑的眼神，安吉拉·马丁式的傲慢表情。保罗·费格走到我身边说，哦，天哪，安吉拉，我刚才在镜头里捕捉到你正在用轻蔑的眼神看简的胸部。他说，
some flowers, but the reason they're so large was because they were a belly hide. There's a great blooper from this as well if you guys go back and rewatch them, but I have a little catch I want to point out. What is it? At six minutes, 44 seconds, I'm standing next to Jan while Andy's doing the tuna, tuna, I bet you get a lot of tuna, eat a lot of tuna, that whole bit. Yep. I just, as an actor, just my own little prep that I decided to do was I just stared at Jan's boobs. I mean, I was eye-leveled to them. She's in heels. She's taller than me. They're right there. And I decided to throw her a little judgy shade, Angela Martin's sass look. And Paul Feed came up to me and was like, oh my gosh, Angela, I just caught in camera that you're giving Jan's boobs the judgy look. He was like,
你每次都得这么做。所以我做了。它被放进了节目里。这只是那些没有写进剧本但最终出现在屏幕上的小瞬间之一，重温这些总是很有趣。但这当然是一个安吉拉会做的时刻。就像，当然，对吧？我很高兴他们捕捉到了它。这也是我们发现的时候，安吉拉，奥索布科至少要三个小时才能准备好。我喜欢帕姆说的那句台词，她说，你是说从现在起三个小时，还是像你开始做的四点钟起三个小时？珍娜，当我重温这一幕时，那是你说的最像现实生活中你的台词之一。
you've got to do that every time. So I did. And it made it in the show. And it's just one of those little moments that wasn't scripted that ends up on the screen and it's always fun to relive those. But that is a big, of course, Angela would do that moment. Like, of course, right? I'm so glad they caught it. This is also when we find out, Angela, that the Asabuco will not be ready for at least three hours. And I love Pam's line when she says, do you mean three hours from now or like three hours from four o'clock when you started it? Jenna, when I rewatch the scene, that is one of the lines that you say that is most like you in real life.
确实。那一刻感觉珍娜就像在以朋友的身份说话。我在想，那会是珍娜。她会说，不，但你提前计划了。肯定。如果你知道它需要三个小时，你肯定会预估你上菜的时间。我觉得这是我在回应主人时可能会说的话。有时在西班牙他们午夜才吃饭。
It is. It just felt like in that moment Jenna was saying it as your friend. I was like, that would be Jenna. She'd be like, no, but you planned ahead. Surely. If you know it takes three hours, surely you would already estimate at the time that you'd be serving it. I feel like that is something I could possibly say in response to a host. Sometimes in Spain they eat at midnight.
所以入乡随俗。入乡随俗。我想我们现在要坐下来喝点酒了。迈克尔敬酒。他提到了葡萄酒的橡木后味。吉恩告诉我史蒂夫即兴发挥了那句台词。你在开玩笑吧。橡木后味。
So when in Rome. When in Rome. I guess we're going to sit around and drink some wine now. Michael makes a toast. He notes the Oki Afterbirth of the wine. Gene told me that Steve improvised that line. You're kidding. Oki Afterbirth.
哦，天哪。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。好吧，现在简需要放松一下。她想放点音乐。是的。我不知道你知不知道，但她以前的助手亨特是一位出色的音乐家。所以她要放他的CD。叫《被猎杀者》。是的，然后她要在我们所有人面前独自跳舞。
Oh my gosh. Steve Carell. Well, now Jan needs to relax. She wants to put some music on. Yeah. And I don't know if you know this, but her former assistant Hunter is a fabulous musician. And so she's going to put on his CD. called The Hunted. Yeah, and then she's going to dance by herself in front of all of us.
我们收到了一些关于那个的粉丝邮件。阿曼达·B、伊莱亚娜·B和盖布·G说，请告诉我们关于简的舞蹈的一切。好吧，我从这个开始。吉恩告诉我，在我们拍了几次马洛拉独自跳舞的镜头后，他有一个想法，她应该试着把吉姆拉进舞蹈中。所以他把她拉到一边，私下给了她那个提示。约翰不知道会发生那种事。马洛拉只是顺其自然。我们也不知道。珍娜，当我重温那一段，现在知道了这一点，对吧？
We got some fan mail about that. Amanda B, Ileana B, and Gabe G. said, please tell us everything about Jan's dance. Well, I'll start with this. Gene told me that after we did a few takes of Malora dancing on her own, he had the idea that she should try to pull Jim into the dance. So he got her aside and he gave her that note privately. John did not know that was going to happen. Malora just ran with it. And we didn't know either. And Jenna, when I rewatched that now knowing that, right?
因为吉恩和你分享了那个。然后马洛拉和我谈了这件事。我观察我们的表情，不仅是约翰的，我还观察了你和我的，因为这对我们三个人来说都是一个惊喜。你真的可以在我们两个人的脸上看到一种表情，就像，什么，发生了什么？太完美了。好吧，就像安吉拉说的，我们确实问了马洛拉这件事，她告诉了我们她跳舞背后的灵感。最有趣的时刻之一是和约翰·卡拉辛斯基一起为亨特写的歌跳舞。这感觉就像是对迈克尔的一种美妙的讽刺，你知道，如此被动攻击。
Because Gene shared that with you. And then Malora talked to me about it. I watched our faces, not only Johns, but I watched yours and mine because it was a surprise to all three of us. And you can really see a look on both of our faces of like, what, what's happening? It was perfect. Well, like Angela said, we did ask Malora about this, and she told us the inspiration behind her dancing. One of the most fun moments to play was the dancing with John Krasinski for the song that Hunter had written. It just felt like such a wonderful sort of jab at Michael, you know, so passive-aggressive.
而且，我是一名舞者，所以我真的只想稍微有点……脱节。我想确保我真的努力做到非常不合适，但也只是稍微有点脱节，有点醉，有点微醺。我觉得这对迈克尔来说会是一个更好的讽刺，因为在这一集的那个时候，简和迈克尔正处于战争状态。我喜欢她有点脱节。哦，是的。简根本不在乎。你知道，这太疯狂了。去想，如果你真的仔细想想，她会在这个尴尬的晚宴上站起来，在他们所有人面前播放一首她以前的情人写给她的歌。
And also, I'm a dancer, so I really wanted to just be a little, like, off. the beat. I wanted to make sure that I really tried hard to just be so inappropriate, but also just like a little bit off the beat, a little drunk, kind of a little tipsy. And I felt like that would be even a better, you know, even a better jab to Michael because Jan and Michael are like at war at that point in the episode. I love that she's a little off the beat. Oh, yeah. Jan just doesn't give a shit. You know, it's so, like, crazy. to think, if you really think it through, that she would get up at this awkward dinner party and play a song her former lover wrote about her and him in front of all of them.
是的！安吉拉，我们收到了很多关于这首歌的邮件。汉娜·H、布里·P、布兰迪·R、迈尔斯·W和里根·C，他们想知道是谁写并演唱了CD上亨特的歌，这是否证明了简和亨特有。一段恋情。是的，我们认为迈克尔在播放这首歌时知道吗？我告诉你们，吉恩和李写了这首歌的歌词。它不是由扮演亨特的演员演唱的。它实际上是由写了音乐的《新色情者》的托德·范西录制和演唱的。但听着，吉恩告诉我，他和李写了一个长得多的版本，歌词非常俗气。
Yes! Angela, we got so much mail about this song. Hannah H. Bree P., Brandy R., Miles W. and Reagan C., they want to know who wrote and performed Hunter's song on the CD, and is it evidence that Jan and Hunter had. a love affair. Yes, and do we think that Michael knew when she played the song? I'll tell you guys, Gene and Lee wrote the words to the song. It was not sung by the actor who played Hunter. It was actually recorded and sung by Todd Fancy of the new pornographers who wrote the music as well. But get this, Gene told me that he and Lee wrote a much longer version of the song with really cheesy lyrics.
他说他们在这上面工作了太久，但他们写这首俗气的情歌玩得很开心。他们有三周时间，所以他们一直在修补。好吧，我想托德也录制了那个加长版，吉恩发给了我一个链接。在加长版中，很明显这首歌是关于简的。很明显他们至少发生过一次性关系。所以我让萨姆剪辑了一个片段，这样我们就能听到这一段。安吉拉，他说，公司规定。
He said they worked on it for way too long, but they were just having so much fun writing this cheesy love song. And they had three weeks, so they kept tinkering. Well, I guess Todd also recorded that extended version of the song, and Gene sent me a link. And in the extended version, it is very clear that this song is about Jan. It is very clear that they have had sex at least once. So I had Sam pull a clip so we can hear this verse. Angela, he said, corporate rules.
去他们的。而且，显然他的父母不喜欢这段关系，因为他也说他不在乎他的父母对此有什么看法。太搞笑了。那个版本也制作得非常精良，有所有其他乐器。我喜欢他们选的那个，因为它更简单。是的。你知道吗？
F them. And also, apparently his parents did not like this relationship because he also says he doesn't care what his parents have to say about it either. It's hilarious. That version is also very produced with all the other instruments. I like the one that they picked because it was more simple. Yes. You know?
然后我也喜欢，当然，安迪不得不去，啊。是的。那每次都让我受不了。那是埃德，你们。那只是埃德把它加进去的。随着场景的继续，我的角色因为传真机的事把你推向了风口浪尖。简又对你不高兴了。我的意思是，我不得不说安吉拉·马丁真的很高兴有人可以一起评判帕姆。
And then I also love, of course, Andy has to go, ah. Yeah. That gets me every time. And that's Ed, you guys. That was just Ed throwing that in there. As the scene continues, my character throws you under the bus about the faxes. Jan is again not happy with you. I mean, I have to say Angela Martin is really happy to have someone to judge Pam with.
我知道。和任何人一起评判。每当有人被评判时，那才是你说话的时候。那就是我建立联系的时候。是的。好吧，帕姆要溜进洗手间。她有一个谈话头。她不在乎别人怎么说。
I know. To judge anyone with. Anytime someone's being judged, that's the only time you speak. That's when I bond. Yes. Well, Pam is going to sneak away to the bathroom. And she has a talking head. She does not care what people say.
说她。她只是想吃东西，她不认为在晚宴上这有什么过分的要求。她在洗手间里说话吗？是的，疯狂的事情是，安吉拉。所以帕姆在洗手间里有这个谈话头。然后吉姆要在洗手间里有一个谈话头，他说主人正在玩他们自己的游戏，让客人感到不舒服，而且他们都赢了。太棒了。约翰和我在一个非常非常小的客用洗手间里。那是我要问的。你知道它看起来像什么吗，珍娜？它看起来像很多家庭都有的那种走廊洗手间。就像半卫。
say about her. She just wants to eat, and she doesn't think it's a lot to ask at a dinner party. Is she talking in the bathroom? Yeah, here's the crazy thing, Angela. So Pam has this talking head in the bathroom. And then Jim is going to have a talking head in the bathroom where he says the hosts are playing their own separate game of making their guests uncomfortable and they're both winning. It's great. John and I are in a real, very tiny guest bathroom. That's what I was going to ask. You know what it looks like, Jenna? It looks like that hall bathroom that a lot of homes have. It's like the half bath.
你知道，它只是一个马桶和一个洗手池，就这样。那是一个半卫。这对我来说很有趣，因为我觉得这本来可以是我们周围放一些假墙之类的东西。但没有，我们在一个真正的洗手间里。里面太小了。保罗·费格实际上谈到了这一点。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？我永远不会忘记被挤进。
You know, it's just like a toilet and a sink, and that's it. It was a half bath. And it's funny to me because I feel like this could have been something where you just put up like little fake walls around us. But no, we were in a real bathroom. It was so tiny in there. Paul Feig actually talks about this. Sam, will you play the clip? I'll never forget being jammed into.
那个小洗手间里，和珍娜还有约翰一起拍摄关于他们感到不舒服的谈话头。我们所有人实际上，我站在洗手池上。我想是兰德尔·艾因霍恩在里面拿着摄像机。这里，马特，马特·佐恩，我们只是挤在这个小东西里拍摄这些谈话头。我从来没笑得这么厉害。我的意思是，天哪。好吧，在这两个小洗手间里的谈话头之间，有一个被删减的场景。它发生在吉姆和帕姆之间。他们躲在洗手间门外的走廊里。珍娜，帕姆正在吃她藏在钱包里之类的燕麦棒。然后简抓住了你们。
that tiny bathroom with Jenna and with John shooting those talking heads about them being uncomfortable. And we were all literally, I was up on a sink. I think it was Randall Einhorn was in there with a camera. Here, Matt, Matt Zone, and we were just jammed in this tiny thing shooting these talking heads. I never laughed so hard. I mean, my God. Well, between these two talking heads in the tiny bathroom, there is a scene that got deleted. It's between Jim and Pam. They are tucked in the hallway outside the bathroom door. And Jenna, Pam is eating a granola bar that she has, like, stashed away in her purse or something. And then Jan bust you guys.
她说，你们在吃什么？太搞笑了。珍娜，你们笑得前仰后合。我们无法拍完它。顺便说一句，我吃了很多燕麦棒，因为保罗·费格说，珍娜，我们必须相信这是你等了几个小时才吃到的饭。你太饿了。所以我吃得满肚子都是燕麦棒。我们一直在笑场。面对马洛拉那双强烈的眼睛，我受不了。我做不到。
She's like, what are you guys eating? It's so funny. And Jenna, you guys were cracking up. We could not get through it. And by the way, I ate so much granola bar because Paul Feig was like, Jenna, we have to believe that this is like the meal you've been waiting hours for. You're so hungry. So I was so full of granola bar. And we kept breaking. Being confronted by Malora with her intense eyes, it did me in. I couldn't do it.
你们俩每次都显得非常吃惊和害怕。然后它就变得非常搞笑。好吧，在客厅里，我们正在进行一场痛苦地现实的猜谜游戏。如果你知道那个游戏的话，其实是名人游戏。我，我，我，我轮到了。我，我，我轮到了。如果你玩任何需要大声给出线索的猜谜或棋盘游戏，你会对一对夫妇了解很多。你真的会了解一对夫妇。珍娜，当我重温这一幕时，我想起了几年前我和另一对夫妇玩的禁忌游戏。那个家伙转向他的妻子说，哦，哦，我总是这样叫你。她说，哦，笨蛋。
You were both like genuinely startled and scared each time. And then it just is hilarious. Well, in the living room, we've got this painfully realistic game of charades going on. A game of celebrity, really, if you know that game. My, my, my, my turn. My, my, my turn. you will learn so much about a couple if you play any kind of charade or board game where you have to like give clues out loud. You really learn a couple. Jenna, when I rewatch this, I thought about a game of taboo I played with another couple years ago. And the guy turned to his wife and goes, oh, oh, I call you this all the time. And she goes, oh, stupid.
不，安吉拉。是的。房间里一片寂静。然后当她猜到时，他就像，是的。他们就像，呜呼。他们在庆祝。我们都像，什么，什么？我们刚刚学到了什么？
No, Angela. Yes. And the room was silent. And then when she got it, he was like, yes. And they were like, woohoo. And they were celebrating. And we were all like, what, what? What did we just learn?
但这就是那一刻。这就是正在发生的事情。我们看到迈克尔和简试图玩游戏。这真是太尴尬了。被动攻击的评论数量令人难以置信。然后吉姆完全在戏弄迈克尔。哦，我知道。他知道迈克尔试图给出汤姆·克鲁斯的线索，但他拒绝说出来。
But this is that moment. This is what is happening. We see Michael and Jan trying to play a game. And it is just so cringy. The amount of passive aggressive comments is incredible. And then Jim is totally messing with Michael. Oh, I know. He knows that Michael is trying to give the clue Tom Cruise, but he refuses to say it.
太棒了，太棒了，太棒了。当然，安吉拉·马丁不懂任何流行文化，所以她帮不上忙。安迪在给出线索方面很糟糕。太糟糕了。现在我们有一个即将到来的时刻，非常有争议。是吉姆试图在派对上甩掉你的时候吗？是的。吉姆假装接到了房东的电话，说他的公寓被淹了，我想，他试图让帕姆和他一起逃离派对。他说，我们得走了。我们很抱歉。
It's so, so, so good. And of course, Angela Martin knows no pop culture, so she's no help. And Andy is horrible at giving clues. Terrible. Now we have a moment coming up that was very controversial. Is it when Jim tried to ditch you at the part? party? Yeah. Jim fakes a phone call from his landlord saying that his apartment is flooded, I guess, and he tries to get Pam to come with him to escape the party. He's like, we got to go. We're so sorry.
这真的太棒了。当然，安吉拉·马丁对流行文化一窍不通，所以她帮不上忙。安迪给提示的能力也很糟糕。太差劲了。现在我们要谈谈一个非常有争议的时刻。是吉姆试图在派对上甩掉你的时候吗？是的。吉姆假装接到房东的电话，说他的公寓被淹了，我想他是想让帕姆跟他一起离开派对。他说，我们得走了。我们很抱歉。
But Michael is like, well, you guys don't both need to go check on the apartment. And Jim is like, okay, great, well, I'll see you at home later than Pam. Yeah. And Pam is like, excuse me, you can buy new stuff, but you can't buy a new party. Yeah, we got a lot of mail about this moment. And Lee Eisenberg actually spoke about this in an interview with Office Talley back when the episode aired. Because I guess after this aired on the East Coast, the message boards blew up with fan comments online. People were really, really mad that Jim would consider leaving Pam behind at this party. But Jean and Lee said they thought it was a really sweet, playful scene.
但迈克尔说，好吧，你们俩不需要都去检查公寓。吉姆说，好吧，太棒了，那晚点在家里见，帕姆。是的。帕姆说，不好意思，你可以买新东西，但你买不到一个新的派对。是的，我们收到了很多关于这一刻的邮件。李·艾森伯格在这一集播出时，曾在接受《Office Talley》采访时谈到过这一点。因为我想在东海岸播出后，留言板上全是粉丝的在线评论。人们真的非常非常生气，吉姆竟然考虑把帕姆一个人留在派对上。但吉恩和李说，他们认为这是一个非常甜蜜、俏皮的场景。
And it sort of was like a mental chess match between Jim and Pam and that Pam ends up winning. And they thought Pam was the victor of this scene. But people could not get past the fact that for a moment, Jim was willing to leave her there. Well, that should tell you how bad the night was going. It didn't really bump me because he included you in the beginning. It's only when he was challenged that he was like, okay, well, I'm gone. Well, the evening has now dissolved into just silence. It's just everyone's sitting around saying nothing.
这就像是吉姆和帕姆之间的一场心理象棋比赛，最后帕姆赢了。他们认为帕姆是这场戏的赢家。但人们无法接受吉姆竟然有一瞬间愿意把她留在那里的事实。好吧，这足以说明那个晚上有多糟糕了。这并没有让我感到不快，因为他一开始就把你包括在内了。只有当他受到挑战时，他才说，好吧，那我就走了。好吧，现在整个晚上都陷入了沉默。每个人都坐在那里一言不发。
And how long have they been sitting there just in silence? I don't know. I mean, Jan is fully reclined with her head back and her eyes closed. Well, Pam gets a little chilly, so Michael offers her his jacket. And this sets off, Jan. This scene is so brilliant. Malora and Steve are so amazing. But her look, the look Malora gives you and then slowly glances back over to Michael and then glances back to Pam.
他们坐在那里沉默了多久？我不知道。我是说，简完全靠在椅背上，闭着眼睛。好吧，帕姆觉得有点冷，所以迈克尔把他的夹克给了她。这激怒了简。这一幕太精彩了。马洛拉和史蒂夫太棒了。但她的眼神，马洛拉看你的眼神，然后慢慢转回迈克尔，又转回帕姆。
And then you see her thinking and planning to say something embarrassing about him. The story Jan tells is that she's very sorry it's so chilly, but they're having to have their sliding door replaced. And you can see a big blue tarp over the door. And the reason is because Michael ran through the glass when he heard the ice cream truck. Yeah, Jan's like, it's a cute story. Michael ran through the sliding glass doors because he thought he heard the ice cream truck. And Michael's like, stop it. I don't like the story.
然后你看到她在思考，计划说一些关于他的尴尬事情。简讲的故事是，她很抱歉这里太冷了，但他们不得不更换滑动门。你可以看到门上盖着一块蓝色的大防水布。原因是因为迈克尔听到冰淇淋车的声音时冲过了玻璃门。是的，简说，这是一个可爱的故事。迈克尔冲过了滑动玻璃门，因为他以为他听到了冰淇淋车的声音。迈克尔说，别说了。我不喜欢这个故事。
Okay, fine, look, I like ice cream. So sue me. And then he's like, wait, I shouldn't say that because she will sue you because she loves lawsuits. And then he said, the glass was extremely clean. And it was like it was invisible. And she just erupts. She's like, you're so right. You're so right.
好吧，好吧，听着，我喜欢冰淇淋。去告我吧。然后他说，等等，我不该这么说，因为她真的会告你，因为她喜欢诉讼。然后他说，那块玻璃太干净了。就像隐形了一样。她突然爆发了。她说，你说得太对了。你说得太对了。
Because before I lived here, the glass was always covered in smudges. And then I moved in and I cleaned it. So I guess that makes me the devil. And then they're both like crazy laughing with like crazy eyes. And he's like, ha, ha, yeah, she is the devil. And it is, oh my God, it's two people unhinged. Here's what Jean told me about this scene, Angela. He told me that the theme of this episode was, quote, dinner party from hell.
因为在我住进来之前，玻璃上总是布满污渍。然后我搬进来，把它擦干净了。所以我想这让我成了魔鬼。然后他们俩都像疯了一样大笑，眼神疯狂。他说，哈哈，是的，她就是魔鬼。天哪，这简直是两个精神失常的人。吉恩是这样告诉我的，安吉拉。他告诉我，这一集的主题是“地狱般的晚宴”。
And the idea was that Michael is in hell and Jan is the devil. And so they did a lot of things toward this theme. For example, they designed Malora's wardrobe so that she was dressed in red. And for this scene where they wrote that line, I guess I'm the devil. And then, you know, Michael responds, and I'm in hell. They purposely placed her in front of a roaring fire. And then in the room, they have all of her candles lit all around Michael so that he does appear to be in the flames of hell. But Malora improvised that moment where she made little devil horn.
这个想法是迈克尔在地狱里，而简是魔鬼。所以他们围绕这个主题做了很多事情。例如，他们设计了马洛拉的服装，让她穿红色的衣服。对于这一幕，他们写了那句台词，“我想我是魔鬼”。然后，你知道，迈克尔回答说，“而我在地狱里”。他们特意把她放在熊熊燃烧的火炉前。在房间里，他们点燃了她所有的蜡烛，环绕着迈克尔，让他看起来确实身处地狱的火焰中。但马洛拉即兴发挥了那个动作，她在头上做了小小的魔鬼角。
on her head, which is so, so funny. But yeah, if you look around this apartment, there's a ton of red stuff. There is. And, you know, I caught at 11 minutes, five seconds, that red pot-like thing that she took when she was fired in the job and it dropped out of the box and they had to put it back in the box, it's seated next to her on the little table. Amazing detail. We're about to go into the kitchen for some girls.
这太搞笑了。但如果你环顾这间公寓，确实有很多红色的东西。确实。而且，你知道，我在11分5秒时捕捉到了那个红色的锅状物，那是她被解雇时拿的，从盒子里掉出来，他们不得不把它放回盒子里，它就放在她旁边的小桌子上。惊人的细节。我们马上要进厨房去享受女孩时光了。
time and in the kitchen, all of her cookware is red. All of that was on purpose. Well, let's talk about this kitchen scene. Pam has wanted to break up the tension in the room. She's like, is there more wine? And Jan's like, no, no, no, I'll get it. No, actually, let's have some girl time. Angela, come on. And she takes them into the kitchen. Well, Jenna, there were a few scenes that we filmed us three gals in this kitchen. Only one made it into the episode, but there is another one. And it's great. Sam, Can you play it? So, this girl that I basically grew up with becomes Miss West Virginia. And then suddenly, all the boys start paying attention to me.
在厨房里，她所有的炊具都是红色的。所有这些都是故意的。好吧，让我们谈谈这个厨房场景。帕姆想打破房间里的紧张气氛。她说，还有酒吗？简说，不，不，不，我去拿。不，其实，让我们享受一下女孩时光。安吉拉，来吧。她把她们带进了厨房。好吧，珍娜，我们三个女孩在这个厨房里拍了几个场景。只有一个进入了这一集，但还有另一个。而且很棒。萨姆，你能播放一下吗？所以，这个我基本上一块长大的女孩成了西弗吉尼亚小姐。然后突然间，所有的男孩都开始关注我了。
And it was funny because, you know, I never even considered myself beautiful until people started pointing it out to me. Now, Jan, wow, you are so much more beautiful than Miss West Virginia. Oh, so that is why I, wait, Pam, what was your question? Where did you grow up? Incredible. Isn't it so good? Yeah. She just goes off about Miss West Virginia and we're just sitting there in silence as she's chopping things. She clearly hates this woman. My question was, where did you grow up? Yeah. And in the kitchen scene, you'll notice I'm standing behind a little ledge by the counter. And I remember Paul Figue and I were so excited that there was a ledge in the kitchen. They didn't have to build that. And I fit perfectly tucked into it so we could hide my belly. Well, while the ladies are having their time in the kitchen, Michael gives the guys a tour of the garage.
这很有趣，因为你知道，我从来没觉得自己漂亮，直到人们开始指出这一点。现在，简，哇，你比西弗吉尼亚小姐漂亮多了。哦，所以这就是为什么我，等等，帕姆，你的问题是什么？你在哪里长大的？不可思议。是不是太棒了？是的。她一直在说西弗吉尼亚小姐的事，而我们只是坐在那里沉默不语，她在那儿切东西。她显然讨厌这个女人。我的问题是，你在哪里长大的？是的。在厨房场景中，你会注意到我站在柜台边的一个小壁架后面。我记得保罗·费格和我当时非常兴奋，厨房里竟然有一个壁架。他们不需要建造那个。我刚好可以缩在里面，这样我们就能藏起我的肚子。好吧，当女士们在厨房享受时光时，迈克尔带着男士们参观了车库。
He also uses this time to try to get them to invest in Serenity by Jan and he's in. You don't need to say more than a sentence to him. This is my daughter's favorite line in the whole episode is when he goes, thought about it. I'm in. Yeah. And Michael's like, do you want to invest $10,000 into this candle business? Think about it. Thought about it.
他还利用这段时间试图让他们投资“简的宁静”蜡烛公司，他加入了。你不需要对他多说一句话。这是我女儿在整集中最喜欢的一句台词，就是他说，“考虑过了。我加入了。”是的。迈克尔说，你想投资1万美元在这个蜡烛生意上吗？考虑一下。考虑过了。
I'm in. Well, when we asked Ed about his memories from shooting the dinner party, he talked about the first time he saw this garage. Sam, can you play that clip? At some point, while we were shooting, I stepped off the set. I think I was probably just going to get a snack or something at craft service. And I watched through the garage of the condo where we were shooting. And the garage was also a location in the episode. They had done all the set decoration for the garage.
我加入了。好吧，当我们问埃德关于拍摄晚宴的记忆时，他谈到了他第一次看到这个车库的情景。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？拍摄期间的某个时候，我走出了片场。我想我可能只是去拿点零食或者去后勤服务处。我透过我们拍摄的公寓车库看去。车库也是这一集的一个地点。他们已经完成了车库的所有布景装饰。
And I noticed this amazing detail in there, which is that all of the items in Michael Scott's garage were things that he had bought from infomercials, like late-night infomercials. And this was just like a background joke in the show. Like I remember seeing like a Bowflex and like a meat dehydrator, like all this random stuff. And it just made me laugh so hard and was such a reminder of how incredible the office team was. everyone at every level from production design, set decoration, all those details, all of those people that worked on the show were so creative and contributing to the comedy of that show in very big and very small ways. And it all made such a difference. Anyway, that's one of my favorite details about that episode. Angela, I looked it up. So currently, a Bowflex system
我注意到里面有一个惊人的细节，那就是迈克尔·斯科特车库里的所有物品都是他从电视购物节目中买来的，比如深夜的电视购物。这只是剧中的一个背景笑话。我记得看到过像Bowflex健身器和肉类脱水机之类的东西。这让我笑得太厉害了，也提醒了我办公室团队是多么不可思议。从制作设计、布景装饰到每一个层面的每个人，所有参与这部剧的人都非常有创意，并以非常大和非常小的方式为这部剧的喜剧效果做出了贡献。这一切都产生了很大的影响。总之，这是我关于那一集最喜欢的细节之一。安吉拉，我查了一下。目前，一套Bowflex系统
starts around $1,500. But Michael had both a bowflex and a solo flex. And a solo flex is like $2,400. And then like Ed said, like meat dehydrator, just any as seen on TV item was shoved into the space. And really pricey stuff. There's two boxes of Lacucet like Dutch ovens. Those are so expensive.
起价约为1500美元。但迈克尔既有Bowflex又有Soloflex。而Soloflex大约要2400美元。就像埃德说的，还有肉类脱水机，任何电视上看到的东西都被塞进了这个空间。而且都是非常昂贵的东西。还有两盒Le Creuset荷兰锅。那些非常贵。
They're like at William Sonoma. And it just kind of is that reminder of when Oscar sat down with him and said, what are you buying? What are you spending your money on? And I don't know if you notice, but there's also just boxes labeled Michael's stuff. Yeah. So clearly Jan went through and just boxed up a bunch of his stuff and it's out there living in the garage. So sad. Oh, yeah.
它们在威廉索诺玛百货卖。这让人想起奥斯卡坐下来问他，你在买什么？你把钱花在什么地方了？我不知道你有没有注意到，还有一些贴着“迈克尔的东西”标签的盒子。是的。所以很明显，简把他的东西打包了，现在它们都放在车库里。太悲哀了。哦，是的。
You know the two chairs by that fireplace were those two hand seats. That's right. But those aren't in the living room anymore. Lady, I think we should take a break. We still have so much more to talk about. Oh my gosh, Dwight and the babysitter haven't even showed up yet. Well, we will get to that right after this break. Ding dong.
你知道壁炉旁的那两把椅子是那两个手型座椅吗？没错。但客厅里已经没有那些了。女士，我想我们应该休息一下。我们还有很多要谈的。天哪，德怀特和保姆还没出现呢。好吧，休息之后我们马上回来。叮咚。
Oh, there's two more guests. Jan is confused. Her whole dinner party is here. Michael is not. He knows who's at the door. It's Dwight and Melvina, his older babysitter from when he was a child. Oh, and don't worry, they've brought two wine glasses and a cooler of food. Yeah.
哦，还有两位客人。简很困惑。她的整个晚宴都在这儿了。迈克尔不是。他知道门口是谁。是德怀特和梅尔维娜，他小时候的年长保姆。哦，别担心，他们带了两个酒杯和一个食物冷藏箱。是的。
Since they're unexpected, they've got it covered, don't worry. And two lawn chairs? So they have a place to sit. The wine glasses are the biggest ones you'll ever see. Yes, they are. This sets off an argument. Jan wants Michael to send them away, but Michael stands his own. ground. Yeah. Michael's like, listen, you said he couldn't come because he didn't have a plus one
既然他们是不速之客，他们已经准备好了，别担心。还有两把草坪椅？这样他们就有地方坐了。那些酒杯是你见过最大的。是的，确实。这引发了一场争论。简想让迈克尔把他们赶走，但迈克尔坚持自己的立场。是的。迈克尔说，听着，你说他不能来是因为他没有带伴侣，
or we didn't have enough wine glasses. Well, he brought the wine glasses and he brought another human. I know. I love that. He's brought a person. A person. So here we go. And Jan is like, fine. Have it your way. And Michael's like, have it my way. When do things ever go my way? Yeah. When he wanted to see stump and she wanted to see Wicked, what did they see? Wicked. When she said she wasn't ready to have children, what did Michael do? He had a vasectomy. Then she decided, I want kids. He had the vasectomy reversed. But then she changed her mind again. He had another vasectomy. Sipsnap, zip snap, zip, sip, snap. Do you know the physical toll that three vasectomies takes on a person? Oh, all of this happens in front of all of us. There is so much to unpack about this scene, guys. So buckle in.
或者我们没有足够的酒杯。好吧，他带了酒杯，还带了另一个人。我知道。我喜欢这一点。他带了一个人。一个人。所以我们开始吧。简说，好吧。随你的便。迈克尔说，随我的便。事情什么时候顺过我的意？是的。当他想看《Stomp》而她想看《Wicked》时，他们看了什么？《Wicked》。当她说她还没准备好要孩子时，迈克尔做了什么？他做了输精管结扎手术。然后她决定，我想要孩子。他做了输精管结扎复通手术。但后来她又改变了主意。他又做了一次输精管结扎手术。咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓。你知道三次输精管结扎手术对一个人身体的伤害有多大吗？哦，所有这些都发生在我们所有人面前。关于这一幕，伙计们，有太多东西可以挖掘了。所以系好安全带。
I mean, when we saw the bench, we thought it can't get weirder than the bench. And then we played celebrity. And now we're standing in the hallway of the condo yelling about vasectomies? Where can it go? Let's start with Dwight's date, his former babysitter Melvina. Angela, Jean told me that they thought it would be really fun to offer this role to our longtime casting director Alison Jones. But she said no.
我是说，当我们看到长凳时，我们以为不会比长凳更奇怪了。然后我们玩了名人游戏。现在我们站在公寓走廊里大喊输精管结扎手术？还能去哪儿？让我们从德怀特的约会对象，他的前保姆梅尔维娜开始。安吉拉，吉恩告诉我，他们认为把这个角色给我们的长期选角导演艾莉森·琼斯会很有趣。但她说不。
She refused. Greg wanted the incredible Beth Grant to play the role. Well, yes, Greg had worked with Beth before and knew her very well. You guys might recognize her from the film No Country for Old Men. I mean, she has a huge filmography, but at this time, that film had just come out. We reached out to Beth. And she told us the story of exactly how she was cast on the show. I was thrilled when I got the call to do this part and to be Rain's babysitter and girlfriend.
她拒绝了。格雷格想让不可思议的贝丝·格兰特来演这个角色。好吧，是的，格雷格以前和贝丝合作过，非常了解她。你们可能在电影《老无所依》中认出她。我是说，她有庞大的电影作品，但在当时，那部电影才刚刚上映。我们联系了贝丝。她告诉我们她是如何被选中出演这部剧的。当我接到电话要演这个角色，成为雷恩的保姆和女朋友时，我非常激动。
It's demented and I love it. And I had worked with Steve Carell fairly recently in Little Miss Sunshine. So I was already completely in love with him and did love the show. and I had worked with Greg Daniels on King of the Hill. And we ran into each other during the Writers Guild Strike. And I think he saw me in my strike mode. I guess he knew I was right to be able to be that demented woman. Well, then Beth shares with us what it was like to do the scene at the front door.
这太疯狂了，我喜欢。而且我最近在《阳光小美女》中和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合作过。所以我已经完全爱上了他，也喜欢这部剧。而且我和格雷格·丹尼尔斯在《乡巴佬希尔》中合作过。我们在编剧协会罢工期间碰到了彼此。我想他看到了我的罢工状态。我想他知道我是扮演那个疯狂女人的合适人选。好吧，然后贝丝和我们分享了在前门拍摄那一幕的感觉。
She's holding a cooler the whole time. This is all happening. It's her first scene of the episode. Here's what she had to say. coming to the door to that dinner party was so thrilling for me. It was so hard not to laugh. I felt that since I knew Steve, he was out to get me. He wanted me to break. And here I was a guest star, nervous with all you regulars, you fabulous comedians, you brilliant comic minds. And here I am the guest star with rain. And opening the door is Steve Carell, just going for it. And I started this riff and improvise.
她一直拿着一个冷藏箱。这一切都在发生。这是她这一集的第一场戏。她是这么说的。来到门口参加那个晚宴对我来说太激动了。忍住不笑太难了。我觉得既然我认识史蒂夫，他就是想整我。他想让我笑场。而我是一个客串明星，和你们这些常驻演员、这些出色的喜剧演员、这些天才的喜剧头脑在一起很紧张。而我是一个和雷恩一起的客串明星。开门的是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，他完全放开了。我开始即兴发挥，
to the point that I was determined not to laugh, so I started almost grunting and crying. I don't know if you can hear it in the episode, and tears in my eyes, and he said, oh, great, now she's crying or something. And I leaned over. I was holding that cooler, you know, bringing our own food since we weren't invited, holding that cooler, and I leaned over, just shaking all over and came back up. and somehow I think I managed not to break. But that was the only time I managed not to break
以至于我下定决心不能笑，所以我开始发出咕哝声和哭声。我不知道你在这一集中能不能听到，我眼里含着泪水，他说，哦，太好了，现在她哭了或者类似的话。我弯下腰。我拿着那个冷藏箱，你知道，因为没被邀请所以自带食物，拿着那个冷藏箱，我弯下腰，全身颤抖，然后又站起来。不知何故，我想我成功地没有笑场。但那是我唯一一次成功没有笑场，
because you guys were just so hilarious. Jenna, we should share with everyone what line Steve improvised that sent us all to the floor. Yes. Guys, Steve improvised the line, snip, snap, snip, snap. You have no idea the physical toll
因为你们实在是太搞笑了。珍娜，我们应该和大家分享史蒂夫即兴发挥的那句台词，让我们所有人都笑趴下了。是的。伙计们，史蒂夫即兴发挥了那句台词，“咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓。你根本不知道
three vasectomies has on a person. I mean, you try not laughing with Steve Corrie. in front of you improvising stuff like that. We were all a goner. Well, it's interesting because Paul Figue sent in an audio clip about this, and I'll let him explain it. But there's a reason why Steve improvised that line. Here you go. There's so many great things to think about and remember from this episode.
三次输精管结扎手术对一个人身体的伤害有多大。”我是说，你试着在史蒂夫·卡瑞尔面前不笑，他即兴发挥这种东西。我们全完了。好吧，这很有趣，因为保罗·费格发来了一段关于此的音频片段，我会让他解释。但史蒂夫即兴发挥那句台词是有原因的。给你。有很多伟大的事情值得思考和记住。
But the one that makes me just realize how genius Steve Corell is in case anybody didn't realize that already, is when the whole SnipSnap run was, it was a a pretty dramatic scene of them, like, talking about having kids and all this. And so we did several takes of it. It was really good, but it was very dramatic. And I remember he's kind of that saying to Steve, maybe let's do a take or just kind of find a little more humor in it. I know it's kind of hard because it's kind of a serious subject. And he's like, oh, okay, yeah, I get it. And that's when he did it, went off on the whole snip, snap, snip, which is just brilliant.
但让我意识到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是多么天才的一件事，以防有人还没意识到，就是当整个“咔嚓”那段戏时，那是一场相当戏剧性的场景，他们谈论要孩子之类的。所以我们拍了好几遍。真的很好，但非常戏剧化。我记得他当时对史蒂夫说，也许我们再拍一遍，或者找点幽默感。我知道这很难，因为这是一个严肃的话题。他说，哦，好吧，是的，我明白了。那就是他即兴发挥整个“咔嚓”那段的时候，这简直太天才了。
I mean, that scene is so funny because it's so heartbreaking and gringy, but also hilarious. I remember that, Angela. I remember doing takes and takes of that scene where they were just going back and forth, and you could just see the pain and Michael that he wasn't a father and that Jan had been so manipulative of him. And it was, it was like a drama. And then Paul came over and talked to Steve. And they were like, how can we make this a comedy again? How can we keep the dark elements of this scene, but not let it get too heavy? Brilliant Steve Carell.
我是说，那一幕太搞笑了，因为它既令人心碎又尴尬，但也非常滑稽。我记得那个，安吉拉。我记得拍了又拍那一幕，他们只是来回争吵，你可以看到迈克尔没有成为父亲的痛苦，以及简对他有多么操纵。这就像是一部剧。然后保罗走过来和史蒂夫谈话。他们说，我们怎么能让它再次变成喜剧？我们怎么能保持这一幕的黑暗元素，但又不让它太沉重？天才的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。
Yeah, he so saves the moment and it's hilarious. I mean, you're cringing. It's horrible. It's, but he makes it funny. Yeah. Well, now guys, we're going to sit down at the table. I guess dinner is ready. Near ready. Finally. Can I point something out? Yeah. If you look at the table, we all have wine glasses, right? We also all have water glasses, which are wine glasses. So clearly, Jan had more than six wine glasses because she is using them for water as well. She just didn't want Dwight to come, you guys, to her fancy party. He did not make the list. Well, Dwight has started eating. I mean, they brought their own food. They're wasting no time.
是的，他拯救了那一刻，而且非常搞笑。我是说，你感到尴尬。这太可怕了。但让他变得很有趣。是的。好吧，现在伙计们，我们要坐在桌子旁了。我想晚餐准备好了。快好了。终于。我可以指出一点吗？是的。如果你看桌子，我们都有酒杯，对吧？我们还有水杯，也就是酒杯。所以很明显，简有超过六个酒杯，因为她也把它们当作水杯用。她只是不想让德怀特来，你们这些家伙，参加她的高级派对。他没在名单上。好吧，德怀特已经开始吃了。我是说，他们自带了食物。他们一点时间也没浪费。
They're the only ones eating. Jan is still upset over what happened at the door. She's so upset. She has to excuse herself. if she goes to the kitchen. Yeah. I mean, the last thing she said before she sat at that dining table was, I hate my life.
他们是唯一在吃东西的人。简还在为门口发生的事情感到不安。她太难过了。她不得不告辞，去了厨房。是的。我是说，她在坐在餐桌前说的最后一句话是，“我讨厌我的生活。”
Yeah. She's not in a good place. Jenna, there's a deleted scene that is so fantastic, where you kind of whisper to Michael, go to Jan. Go comfort her. You kind of do this little motion, like, go say something. So he gets up and he walks over to her. Again, he's comforting her, but we're all witness to it.
是的。她的状态不好。珍娜，有一个被删减的场景太棒了，你有点对迈克尔耳语，“去找简。去安慰她。”你做了这个小动作，就像，去说点什么。所以他站起来走向她。同样，他在安慰她，但我们都目睹了这一切。
And it's so clumsy and awkward. And Sam, can you play the first part of that? Hey, no, no, no. Don't be sad. Don't be sad. Look, I care about you and I support you. And you are smart and beautiful. And you have beautiful bosoms.
而且非常笨拙和尴尬。萨姆，你能播放第一部分吗？嘿，不，不，不。别难过。别难过。看，我在乎你，我支持你。你聪明又漂亮。而且你有美丽的胸部。
And you can't even tell her fake unless you're naked. And I believe that with. my support and your constant calls to Dr. Perry on my phone plan, with a little bit of a strain, because I only have 20 anytime minutes a month. Every minute after that is 75 cents. You should look at some other plans. Okay, thanks, weirdo, but you know what? I'm month to month because I don't want a two-year commitment. I remember when he turned to Beth and goes, Oh, thanks, weirdo. We all lost it. Yeah. Gene said that's one of his favorite lines that got cut.
除非你裸体，否则你甚至看不出是假的。我相信在我的支持下，加上你不断用我的手机套餐给佩里医生打电话，虽然有点吃力，因为我每个月只有20分钟的随时通话时间。之后每分钟75美分。你应该看看其他套餐。好吧，谢谢，怪胎，但你知道吗？我是按月付费的，因为我不想有两年的承诺。我记得当他转向贝丝说，“哦，谢谢，怪胎。”我们所有人都笑疯了。是的，吉恩说那是他最喜欢的被删减的台词之一。
Oh, really? Mm-hmm. He loves that moment. Michael continues to try to comfort Jan, and it doesn't get any better, but it really paints a picture of how he feels about his home life with her. What were you saying to Jan? Honey, nobody in the complex likes you, but you have made this place a lot great. It's like a museum. You can't touch anything, which is a really strange way to feel in the place that you live. You have made this home a house.
哦，真的吗？嗯。他喜欢那一刻。迈克尔继续试图安慰简，情况并没有好转，但这确实描绘了他对与她共同生活的感受。你对简说了什么？亲爱的，这个小区里没人喜欢你，但你让这个地方变得很棒。就像博物馆一样。你什么都不能碰，这在你住的地方是一种非常奇怪的感觉。你让这个家变成了一所房子。
It's just what Paul Feig said about their design of the house. Yes, like a museum. You have made this warm, cozy home a house. Oh, Michael. I think they were right to leave those out because otherwise, I think we might have felt too badly for Jan when Michael is about to do what he's about to do. But before we get there, Angela, I have to talk about this moment when Dwight offers you some of his beet salad and you respond by saying the thought of popping one of his beats into your mouth makes you want to vomit. because I remember something else that was happening during this scene. Will you share it with us?
这正是保罗·费格所说的关于他们对房子的设计。是的，就像博物馆一样。你让这个温暖、舒适的家变成了一所房子。哦，迈克尔。我认为他们删掉这些是对的，否则，当迈克尔即将做他要做的事情时，我们可能会对简感到太难过了。但在那之前，安吉拉，我必须谈谈德怀特给你一些甜菜沙拉，而你回答说，想到把他的甜菜放进嘴里就让你想吐的那一刻。因为我记得那一幕发生时还有别的事情。你能和我们分享一下吗？
Yeah, it was actually really hard for me to focus in this scene and say my dialogue because Jenna, my daughter in my belly just decided in that moment she was going to run a full marathon. She was like diga-dick, dig-d-d-d-d-dick, kicking so much. I don't know, maybe it's the sound of Rayne Wilson's voice. Maybe Rain's voice awoken to my child in my womb and she was ready to find. But it was so surreal to me to be thinking about the timing of the scene and everyone's dialogue and when I was supposed to come in and trying not to laugh. In the meantime, having this like wrestling match happening in my belly. I think there are a lot of women who can relate to that, Angela. I have a
是的，在那一幕中我真的很难集中注意力说台词，因为珍娜，我肚子里的女儿在那一刻决定要跑一场全程马拉松。她在那儿踢得太厉害了。我不知道，也许是雷恩·威尔逊声音的原因。也许雷恩的声音唤醒了我子宫里的孩子，她准备好战斗了。但对我来说，思考这一幕的时间安排、每个人的台词以及我什么时候该进来，同时还要努力不笑，这太超现实了。与此同时，我的肚子里还在发生这种摔跤比赛。我想有很多女性能感同身受，安吉拉。我有一个
friend who is a lawyer and she was very, very pregnant and she was having to take a deposition. And she told me at the end of the day, she was like, I could barely focus on what I was doing because I was having to give very carefully worded questions and comments because it was all going on the record, but all the while her kid in her belly was just tossing and turning. Yeah. So much so. And I have shared this story before, and it's one of my favorite memories. While the scene was going on, I'm talking everyone is saying their lines and there's the
朋友是律师，她当时怀孕非常非常久了，她不得不进行一次取证。她告诉我，一天结束时，她说，我几乎无法专注于我在做的事情，因为我不得不给出非常谨慎措辞的问题和评论，因为这一切都要记录在案，但与此同时，她肚子里的孩子一直在翻来覆去。是的。太强烈了。我以前分享过这个故事，这是我最喜欢的记忆之一。当这一幕发生时，我在说话，每个人都在说他们的台词，还有
rapid cadence of the dialogue. I, off camera, grabbed Ed's hand and under the table put it on my, belly and he turned to me with his eyes wide and all of a sudden he wasn't Andy he was Ed and he mouthed to me oh my gosh I needed someone else to know and to witness like what I was like going through in the moment and it's such a special memory to me and when I rewatched the episode with my daughter I said Isabel you were running a marathon in mommy's belly right now and she was like what it's so special to me Guys, women are warriors.
快速的对话节奏。我在镜头外抓住了埃德的手，在桌子底下放在我的肚子上，他瞪大眼睛转向我，突然间他不再是安迪，而是埃德，他对我口型说，“天哪。”我需要别人知道并见证我当时正在经历的事情，这对我来说是一个非常特别的记忆。当我带着女儿重看这一集时，我说，“伊莎贝尔，你当时在妈妈肚子里跑马拉松呢。”她说，“什么？”这对我来说太特别了。伙计们，女性是战士。
We go to work and we focus on our work as if we don't have that going on. Try to imagine how I could put it to a man. Like, okay, you're trying to give the most important presentation of your life and imagine a puppy is jumping at your leg the whole time. Like, just the most distracting thing. Jumping at your leg, but it's inside you, which is even weirder. Yeah. It's like the alien.
我们去工作，我们专注于工作，好像我们没有这些事情发生一样。试着想象我怎么把它比作男人。比如，好吧，你正试图进行你一生中最重要的演讲，想象一只小狗一直在跳你的腿。就像，最让人分心的事情。跳你的腿，但它在你里面，这更奇怪。是的。就像外星人。
What is happening? Women are warriors. Way to go, Angie. Beth Grant also shared her memories about shooting this dinner table scene. Let's have a listen. Sitting at that table and, you know, sucking on those beats. The reason I was sucking on those beats was to keep from laughing and rains over there eating and going, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, there's so much subtle humor in this episode. And then, of course, the demented relationship that they have. I love you all so much. I'm so honored to be part of this very popular and respected episode, each of you doing such beautiful, subtle, hilarious comedy. And I was so thrilled to see that all of you broke up to, once we got inside and we sat down
发生了什么？女性是战士。干得好，安吉。贝丝·格兰特也分享了她拍摄这场餐桌戏的记忆。让我们听听。坐在那张桌子旁，你知道，吮吸那些甜菜。我吮吸那些甜菜的原因是为了忍住不笑，雷恩在那儿吃着，发出“嗯，嗯，嗯，嗯，嗯，嗯”的声音。这一集中有太多微妙的幽默。当然，还有他们那种疯狂的关系。我非常爱你们所有人。我很荣幸能参与这一集非常受欢迎和受人尊敬的剧集，你们每个人都表演了如此美丽、微妙、搞笑的喜剧。我很高兴看到你们所有人都笑场了，一旦我们进去坐下
the table and someone would break and say, sorry, sorry, and then someone else would break, sorry, sorry, and then we'd keep going. The last thing I'll say is when I came home, I said, I do not know how Paul is going to edit this. It's too hilarious. Every moment is a three-hour episode. I don't understand how he's going to do it. But by golly, you did it.
桌子旁，有人会笑场说，“抱歉，抱歉”，然后另一个人会笑场，“抱歉，抱歉”，然后我们继续。我要说的最后一件事是，当我回家时，我说，“我不知道保罗要怎么剪辑这个。太搞笑了。每一刻都是一部三小时的剧集。我不明白他要怎么做。”但天哪，你做到了。
And it is just an honor to have been part of this amazing, and as I say again, demented episode. Amazing and demented. That sums it up. Yeah. Jean told me that he and Lee actually begged NBC to make this a supersized episode. But I guess the schedule had already been. set. But he also told me that they did end up releasing a 29-minute producers cut on iTunes that included a bunch of deleted scenes, including some of the ones we talked about, like the
能参与这一部令人惊叹的，正如我再次所说，疯狂的剧集，真是一种荣幸。令人惊叹和疯狂。这总结了一切。是的。吉恩告诉我，他和李实际上恳求NBC把这一集做成超长版。但我猜时间表已经定好了。但他还告诉我，他们最终在iTunes上发布了一个29分钟的制片人剪辑版，其中包括了一堆被删减的场景，包括我们谈到的一些，比如
granola bar scene. Maybe NBC didn't supersize it because they were holding a grudge because Greg wanted it to go as is. Oh, wow. I love that speculation. They're like, no, you can have your weirdo episode, but it's only going to be 22 minutes. We're not going to make it big. That's what she said. Oh, that's what she said. One other little detail from this dinner party is how enormous the glasses were that Dwight was drinking from. To me, they look like glasses you buy at Spencer's Gifts. Remember that place in the mall where you could get like kind of joke-sized stuff?
燕麦棒场景。也许NBC没有把它做成超长版是因为他们怀恨在心，因为格雷格想让它保持原样。哦，哇。我喜欢这种猜测。他们就像，“不，你可以有你的怪胎剧集，但它只有22分钟。我们不会把它做大的。”这就是她说的。哦，这就是她说的。关于这个晚宴的另一个小细节是德怀特喝水的杯子有多大。对我来说，它们看起来像你在Spencer's Gifts买的杯子。还记得商场里那个你可以买到那种笑话大小东西的地方吗？
Well, Paul really loved these glasses, and there was one detail about them he wanted to share with us. One of my favorite gags in the show is when Dwight comes over with his babysitter and they're, it didn't. with the wine glasses. I had them filled the wine all the way to the top because I figured that's what Dwight would think you would do with a big wine glasses. You would fill it right to the rim. So that's a little wine lover's joke for everybody. You know what they look like to me, Angela? They look like those wine glasses that I see a lot of moms post on Instagram about getting through their day. Wine Weekend with the ladies and the wine glasses like the size of your head? Yes. That's what they remind me of.
好吧，保罗真的很喜欢这些杯子，有一个关于它们的细节他想和我们分享。我在剧中最喜欢的笑话之一是德怀特带着他的保姆过来，他们拿着酒杯。我让他们把酒倒满，因为我想这就是德怀特认为你会用大酒杯做的事情。你会把它倒到边缘。所以这是一个给每个人的小酒迷笑话。你知道它们在我看来像什么吗，安吉拉？它们看起来像我在Instagram上看到很多妈妈发的关于度过一天的那种酒杯。和女士们一起的葡萄酒周末，酒杯像你的头那么大？是的。这就是它们让我想起的样子。
Yeah. Oh my God, lady, guess what? What? The food is ready. The food is ready, but it might be poisoned. Oh, no. Oh my gosh, yes. Michael whispers to Pam. He thinks that Jan has maybe been trying to poison him. He can't prove it, but he thinks. He just hopes she didn't do anything to the food tonight. Like, what has been happening to Michael? Has he been having violent diarrhea? Stomach cramping after he eats with her? Like, what is making him? think this? Pam has a talking head. Poor Pam is so hungry. She says she knows that Jan did not poison the food. But if she were going to poison the food, wouldn't she have poisoned Pam's since she is Michael's former lover? And now you know Pam is not going to be able to eat. You guys, Michael has soft teeth. We learned that in this episode. And because of his soft teeth,
是的。天哪，女士，你猜怎么着？什么？食物准备好了。食物准备好了，但它可能有毒。哦，不。天哪，是的。迈克尔对帕姆耳语。他认为简可能一直在试图毒死他。他无法证明，但他认为。他只是希望她今晚没在食物里做什么手脚。比如，迈克尔到底发生了什么？他一直在剧烈腹泻吗？和她一起吃饭后胃痉挛？比如，是什么让他这么想的？帕姆有一个谈话头。可怜的帕姆太饿了。她说她知道简没有在食物里下毒。但如果她要下毒，难道她不应该给帕姆下毒吗，因为她是迈克尔的前情人？现在你知道帕姆没法吃了。伙计们，迈克尔有软牙。我们在这一集中学到了这一点。因为他的软牙，
He has to dip his meat into his wine or probably whatever beverage is in front of him. And Jan hates it. This has clearly come up before. And she doesn't want him to do it. She's like, could you stop doing it? It's disgusting. Lady, can I tell you a story about a guy I dated? Oh, God.
他必须把肉蘸进酒里，或者可能是他面前的任何饮料里。简讨厌这样。这显然以前发生过。她不想让他这样做。她说，“你能别这样吗？太恶心了。”女士，我能给你讲一个我约会过的男人的故事吗？哦，天哪。
I was so worried you were about to tell me you dip meat into your beverages. But it's about a different, it's a guy. Angela, how long have you known me? You thought maybe I dip my meat? and beverages? Well, you've made a face. You guys can't see her, but she made a face. You did the thing with your shoulders that you do, Jenna, when you're about to share something with me that you haven't shared before. And so I thought, oh my God, I've eaten with her, but have I ever eaten red meat with her? Oh my God. No, I eat meat normally. I can't believe that's a sentence I had to say. Well, but I did. No, what I was going to share was,
我太担心你要告诉我你把肉蘸进饮料里了。但这是关于另一个，是一个男人。安吉拉，你认识我多久了？你以为我可能蘸我的肉？在饮料里？好吧，你做了一个鬼脸。你们看不到她，但她做了一个鬼脸。你做了你肩膀上的那个动作，珍娜，当你准备和我分享一些你以前没分享过的事情时。所以我心想，天哪，我和她一起吃过饭，但我吃过红肉吗？天哪。不，我正常吃肉。我不敢相信这是一句我不得不说的句子。好吧，但我确实。不，我要分享的是，
I dated a guy who first of all had to drink milk with every meal, not water. Gross. He was a grown man, but he had to have a big tall glass of milk. I mean, maybe no judgment, but I'm just saying, I don't know. I judge. Okay, go on. We're at a restaurant. Orders a tall glass of milk.
我约会过一个男人，首先他每顿饭都必须喝牛奶，而不是水。恶心。他是个成年男人，但他必须有一大杯牛奶。我是说，也许不予置评，但我只是说，我不知道。我评判。好吧，继续。我们在餐厅。点了一大杯牛奶。
Okay. But he had this thing where he would take a bite of food and then immediately take a sip of milk and then chew the food. and then chew the food with the milk in his mouth and then swallow it. Oh, God. And you had to sit and watch that through a whole meal? This was his preferred way of eating. He liked the taste of his food mixed with a sip of milk. All foods?
好吧。但他有一个习惯，他会咬一口食物，然后立即喝一口牛奶，然后咀嚼食物。然后嚼着嘴里有牛奶的食物，然后吞下去。哦，天哪。你不得不坐着看完整顿饭？这是他首选的进食方式。他喜欢食物混合着一口牛奶的味道。所有食物？
Every meal. Every food. A bite of sandwich, sip of milk. A fork full of spaghetti, sip of milk. That is disgusting. That's a deal breaker for me. I can't spend the rest of my life watching you take one bite, a swig of milk, and slosh it around. I can't do it.
每顿饭。每种食物。一口三明治，一口牛奶。一叉子意大利面，一口牛奶。太恶心了。这对我来说是交易破坏者。我不能余生看着你咬一口，喝一口牛奶，然后在那儿晃荡。我做不到。
I'm out. I dated him a long time. How long? I don't want to say. Oh, no. Oh, no. But it was a lot of meals. A lot of milk meals.
我退出了。我和他约会了很长时间。多久？我不想说。哦，不。哦，不。但那有很多顿饭。很多牛奶餐。
Yeah. Well, listen, Michael is really offended that Jan has pointed out this quirk in front of the dinner party. and she is so evil. She goes, oops. And that's it. Michael has had it. He is going to take back his space. He marches off. We don't know where he's going or what he's getting. While he's gone, I got a little glimpse of your plate, Angela. Yeah? Will you please tell people what you did? You guys, it was one of those little actory moments and it might also have been because I was really pregnant and everything was smelling so strong to me. but I took my napkin, my fancy napkin that Jan had laid out for all of us, and I just gently covered my meat with it so I didn't have to look at it. And I thought Angela Martin would do that because she's a vegetarian. She wouldn't have eaten the meat or wanted to look at it. But she wasn't
是的。好吧，听着，迈克尔真的很生气，简在晚宴前指出了这个怪癖。她太邪恶了。她说，“哎呀。”就这样。迈克尔受够了。他要夺回他的空间。他大步走开。我们不知道他要去哪儿，也不知道他要拿什么。当他离开时，我瞥了一眼你的盘子，安吉拉。是吗？你能告诉大家你做了什么吗？伙计们，那是那种小演员时刻之一，也可能是因为我怀孕了，所有东西对我来说闻起来都很强烈。但我拿了我的餐巾，简为我们所有人铺好的高级餐巾，我轻轻地盖住了我的肉，这样我就不用看它了。我想安吉拉·马丁会那样做，因为她是素食主义者。她不会吃肉或想看它。但她不会
going to say anything because this is clearly not the dinner party where you want to voice up about the food. So I covered my meat with the napkin. So brilliant. I love that choice. Well, Michael comes back to the table and he has brought with him his neon beer sign and he takes a painting off the wall, which by the way I want to point out is red. And he hangs up his beer sign. And when the neon light goes on, you hear the hum and we are just bathed in this glow from this sign. Well, listen, it's a St. Paulie girl beer sign and it's outlined in blue. So when he turned it on, it was like a cascade of blue light filled the whole room.
说什么，因为这显然不是你想对食物发表意见的晚宴。所以我用餐巾盖住了我的肉。太天才了。我喜欢那个选择。好吧，迈克尔回到桌子旁，他带来了他的霓虹啤酒招牌，他从墙上取下了一幅画，顺便说一句，我想指出它是红色的。他挂上了他的啤酒招牌。当霓虹灯亮起时，你听到了嗡嗡声，我们都被这招牌发出的光芒沐浴着。好吧，听着，这是一个圣保利女孩啤酒招牌，边缘是蓝色的。所以当他打开它时，就像一股蓝光倾泻而下，充满了整个房间。
It's just so incredible. And you see the blue on Malora's face. That's how bright the light is. Jan is furious. She gets up. She turns on Hunter's CD. And now we are going to have the argument. Yeah.
太不可思议了。你可以看到马洛拉脸上的蓝色。这就是光有多亮。简很愤怒。她站起来。她打开了亨特的CD。现在我们要开始争论了。是的。
We thought we had the argument, but now the showdown is about to happen. Yeah. They start arguing about talent, about creativity. Michael's like, I don't think he's a good singer. I don't think he's very good at all. But Jan seems to love him. It's one of my favorite lines. Jan says, at least he's an artist.
我们以为我们已经争论过了，但现在摊牌要开始了。是的。他们开始争论天赋，关于创造力。迈克尔说，“我不认为他是个好歌手。我不认为他有多好。”但简似乎很爱他。这是我最喜欢的台词之一。简说，“至少他是个艺术家。”
And Michael says, BFD, I'm a screenwriter. And this is my favorite line. Jan says, and I'm a candle maker, but you don't hear me bragging about it. It's one of my favorite lines of the whole episode. I also like this couplet. You burn it, you buy it. And then Michael says, great, I'll be your first customer. You're hardly my first.
迈克尔说，“去他的，我是个编剧。”这是我最喜欢的台词。简说，“而我是个蜡烛制造者，但你没听我吹嘘过。”这是我整集中最喜欢的台词之一。我也喜欢这对对联。“你烧了它，你就买了它。”然后迈克尔说，“太好了，我会成为你的第一个顾客。”“你才不是我的第一个。”
I cannot believe we got to sit in that room. I know. I mean, we got front row seats to this live show. It was mind-blowing. Just the. the two of them were doing this dance and we got to watch it. I am still blown away that we got to be there. Well, when we asked Rain Wilson about this episode, this is what he talked about.
我不敢相信我们能坐在那个房间里。我知道。我是说，我们得到了这场现场表演的前排座位。太令人震惊了。只是他们两个在跳这支舞，我们得以观看。我仍然对我们能在那儿感到震惊。好吧，当我们问雷恩·威尔逊关于这一集时，这就是他谈到的。
I think the true hero of Dinner Party is the magnificent Malora Hardin, who is insanely brilliant all through the series, but especially in that episode. I mean, Steve Corral being one of the all-time greats on the planet Earth comedic actors, and Malora Hardin stands toe to toe with him all the way through it being just as funny, just as specific, just as weird. And it's where you kind of see that Jan has turned a corner and that there is underneath this kind of external facade of blonde efficiency. there is a very, very weird, egotistical, messed up human being under there. Her candles, on and on. But her performance is just magnificent. It's so dry.
我认为《晚宴》真正的英雄是伟大的马洛拉·哈丁，她在整个系列中都极其出色，尤其是在那一集中。我是说，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是地球上最伟大的喜剧演员之一，而马洛拉·哈丁在整个过程中与他并驾齐驱，同样有趣，同样具体，同样怪异。这就是你看到简已经转过弯的地方，在金发效率的外表下，有一个非常、非常怪异、自负、搞砸了的人类。她的蜡烛，等等。但她的表演简直太棒了。太干练了。
It stands the test of time as just one of the great all-time performances all throughout the series, but especially in that episode. When I re-watched it recently with my son, I was blown away by how great she was. Malora is the star of this episode. She just is. Yeah. We were so lucky to have her. I mean, back on the pilot when we cast her, could we have known that this is what was going to happen? Well, Jenna, Malora has shared with us that she felt like they knew the chemistry these characters could have if they really got room to run. Way back on the pilot, here's what she had to say. The whole Jan and Michael arc started. when we were having lunch at the pilot episode, me and Steve and Greg were all having lunch together. And somehow Steve and I both said, like, there was just some spark and some weird dysfunctional attraction between Michael and Jan that if we ever got so lucky to make the series, we would hope that we could get them to hook up somehow, some way at some conference or something. So that was the beginning of it. So I think going into it, I was always aware of what the potential for.
这绝对是整部剧中最伟大的表演之一，经得起时间的考验，尤其是在那一集中。最近我和儿子重温时，她出色的表现让我惊叹不已。梅洛拉（Malora）是这一集的明星，她就是。是的，我们能拥有她真是太幸运了。我是说，当初试播集选角时，我们怎么可能预见到会发生这一切呢？嗯，珍娜（Jenna），梅洛拉曾告诉我们，她觉得他们当时就知道，如果给这些角色发挥的空间，他们之间会产生怎样的化学反应。早在试播集时，她是这么说的：整个简（Jan）和迈克尔（Michael）的故事线始于我们在拍摄试播集时一起吃午饭，我和史蒂夫（Steve）还有格雷格（Greg）都在一起。不知怎么的，我和史蒂夫都觉得，迈克尔和简之间有一种火花，一种奇怪的、功能失调的吸引力。如果我们有幸能把这个系列拍下去，我们希望他们能以某种方式，在某个会议或其他场合勾搭上。这就是一切的开始。所以我认为在拍摄过程中，我一直很清楚这种潜力。
or sort of showing this wonderfully complicated and dysfunctional relationship was the hilarity of that. It was just so funny and so kind of dark, darkly funny, which just really appeals to my personal sensibilities. I really loved that the dinner party took it to that next step of implosion. Yeah, it was just thrilled. It was just thrilled that we had a chance to really implode on screen in front of everybody. and hopefully get a lot of laughs out of it, which we did. Well, speaking of implosion, this whole thing is about to crescendo
或者说，展现这种极其复杂且功能失调的关系本身就充满了滑稽感。这太有趣了，而且带有一种黑暗的幽默感，非常符合我的个人品味。我真的很喜欢“晚宴”这一集将这种崩溃推向了新的高度。是的，我非常激动，我们有机会在屏幕上、在所有人面前真正地爆发出来，并希望从中获得很多笑声，我们也确实做到了。说到爆发，整件事即将达到高潮
when Jan picks up a dundee and smashes Michael's beloved plasma screen TV. Yeah, I mean, he's like, that was too hot back on your $0 salary, babe. I, my favorite moment after that, there's the silence of like, oh, my God, what just happened? And the person that calls it for the night that's like, yeah, I'm done here, is Melvina. She's like, yeah, I'm going to go. Well, Melvin is the only person who doesn't work for this guy.
当简拿起一个邓迪奖杯（Dundee）砸向迈克尔心爱的等离子电视时。是的，他说：“那可是你零薪水买不起的昂贵货，宝贝。”我最喜欢的时刻是那之后，那种“天哪，刚才发生了什么？”的沉默。而那个决定离开、说“我受够了”的人是梅尔维娜（Melvina）。她说：“好吧，我要走了。”毕竟梅尔维娜是唯一一个不为这家伙工作的人。
So she could be like, yeah, I'm out of here. Yeah. This has taken a turn for me. Well, we had a fan question, Angela, from Meg, Emily. Ethan and Emma, how many plasma screen TVs were broken by a Dundee? And how many takes did this actually require? Well, I reached out to good old Kentopedia who told me that those little TVs were actually kind of expensive.
所以她可以表现得“好吧，我走了”。“这对我来说有点过分了。”嗯，安吉拉，我们收到了来自梅格（Meg）、艾米丽（Emily）、伊森（Ethan）和艾玛（Emma）的粉丝提问：邓迪奖杯砸坏了多少台等离子电视？这实际上拍了多少次？嗯，我联系了万能的肯托百科（Kentopedia），他告诉我那些小电视其实挺贵的。
He said, they bought five of them and we broke four. Now, I remember doing a bunch of takes with Malora where she missed at first and they would have us react as if she hit it. They could always use our reaction, but then she only had those five chances to actually land the Dundee when she was on camera. And you know, I mean, the sort of comical thing is it wasn't a big target. It wasn't. It's a small thing to hit square in the middle with a Dundee. It's true.
他说他们买了五台，我们砸坏了四台。我记得和梅洛拉拍了很多次，起初她没砸中，他们让我们表现得好像她砸中了一样。他们总是可以用我们的反应镜头，但她只有那五次机会在镜头前真正砸中邓迪奖杯。你知道，滑稽的是，那并不是一个很大的目标。确实不是。用邓迪奖杯精准地砸中中心是很困难的。确实如此。
Well, we're all going to follow Melvina out the door, right? Everyone gets up from the table. They're going to leave. I was actually asked not to get up from the table if you notice. And it's because you would have seen my belly. So I'm the last to leave the dining room. Well, not only do we leave, but the police arrive. There are two moments that are so delicious in the scene.
好吧，我们都要跟着梅尔维娜出门了，对吧？每个人都从桌边站起来，准备离开。其实我被要求不要从桌边站起来，如果你注意到了的话。这是因为如果你站起来就会看到我的肚子。所以我最后一个离开餐厅。嗯，我们不仅离开了，警察也来了。这一幕中有两个时刻非常精彩。
Well, one of my first things is right away, the police officers are like, hey, Dwight, because they know him because he's always hanging around them. He, like, wants to be part of the club. And the other thing is, is when Michael says to them, As if they know what he's talking about, he says, my girlfriend threw a dundee at my TV. Yeah. Can you imagine? Well, they ask if he wants to press charges because some neighbors heard a lot of yelling, a big domestic disturbance.
嗯，我最先注意到的事情之一是，警察一进来就说：“嘿，德怀特（Dwight）”，因为他们认识他，他总是围着他们转。他就像是想加入那个圈子。另一件事是，当迈克尔对他们说——好像他们知道他在说什么一样——他说：“我女朋友拿邓迪奖杯砸了我的电视。”是的，你能想象吗？他们问他是否要起诉，因为邻居们听到了很大的吵闹声，是一场严重的家庭纠纷。
And Michael says, I'll take the fall. And they're like, no, I, there's, you're actually, you're actually not in fault. You don't have to take the fall. Is there anywhere you can go tonight? Yeah, and Dwight offers to take Michael home with him, which Michael refuses until he sees Jan come out of the condo and then he's like, yeah, yeah, okay, no, I'll go home with you. Well, Jenna, as everyone is leaving, there was a Dwight and Angela deleted scene, and Angela is very sassy with Dwight. I want to play it. I noticed you wearing open-toed shoes.
迈克尔说：“我来承担责任。”他们说：“不，你其实没做错什么，你不需要承担责任。今晚有地方去吗？”是的，德怀特提出让迈克尔跟他回家，迈克尔拒绝了，直到他看到简从公寓里出来，然后他说：“好吧，好吧，行，我跟你回家。”嗯，珍娜，在每个人离开时，有一个德怀特和安吉拉的删减片段，安吉拉对德怀特非常刻薄。我想放一下。我注意到你穿了露趾鞋。
Since when did you become a whore? There might be a lot of things about me that shock you. Now, if you excuse me, I have to get back to my date. There might be a lot of things about me that shock you. And then I look them up and down, and I coyly kind of smile, and I walk away. And now there's this series of scenes, right, that kind of wrap up the episode. There's a montage of Jan. She's trying to fix the Dundee.
你什么时候变得这么放荡了？关于我，可能有很多事情会让你感到震惊。现在，请原谅，我得回去约会了。关于我，可能有很多事情会让你感到震惊。然后我上下打量他们，羞涩地笑了笑，走开了。现在有一系列场景，对吧，算是给这一集做了收尾。有一个关于简的蒙太奇片段，她试图修理那个邓迪奖杯。
you can tell she's sad. She knows this night went horrible, clearly knows this is a night they might not come back from, right? Yeah. You see Jim and Pam having this really cute scene. They finally got food. They're having a hamburger. Yes.
你可以看出她很伤心。她知道今晚过得太糟糕了，显然知道这是一个他们可能无法挽回的夜晚，对吧？是的。你看到吉姆（Jim）和帕姆（Pam）有这一段非常可爱的场景。他们终于吃到了东西，他们在吃汉堡。是的。
We got a fan question about this from Reagan Collinor who wants to know what burger place did Jim and Pam eat at the end because the burgers looked amazing. I'll tell you what, the burgers were amazing. I don't know if it was just. because I'd spent four days saying I was hungry, but when I got that burger, I'm really eating it in that scene. I think you can tell. I think you were happy to eat anything other than that granola bar. I think I was. Well, we filmed that scene at the home plate burger joint. And it was this little mom and pop hamburger stand, which eventually, sadly, went out of business. It's now a smog shop. And in that same strip mall, there was a car wash that they turned into a cold stone creamery. And that is where Andy and Angela are sitting in the car, having their ice cream. Yes. Ed and I have a very funny story about this moment. And I asked Ed,
我们收到了里根·科林诺（Reagan Collinor）的粉丝提问，想知道吉姆和帕姆最后是在哪家汉堡店吃的，因为汉堡看起来太棒了。我告诉你，汉堡确实很棒。我不知道是不是因为我饿了四天，但当我拿到那个汉堡时，我在那一幕里是真的在吃。我想你看得出来。我想你很高兴能吃到除了那根燕麦棒以外的任何东西。我想是的。嗯，我们在“本垒板”（Home Plate）汉堡店拍的那场戏。那是一家小型的夫妻汉堡店，后来很遗憾倒闭了。现在变成了一家烟雾检查店。在同一个购物中心里，有一家洗车店被改成了酷圣石（Cold Stone Creamery）冰淇淋店。那就是安迪（Andy）和安吉拉坐在车里吃冰淇淋的地方。是的，埃德（Ed）和我关于这一刻有一个非常有趣的故事。我问埃德，
I texted him. I said, Ed, can I share about the car scene? And he's like, yes, you can tell everyone I farted it in the car. So we're in the car and he's supposed to lick a little bit of my ice cream. and then I have to squish it on the side, right? It took a few tries to get that squish just right. And in between setting up, they'd have to clean the door and we're in between setups. And Ed had a little toot. And I was really pregnant, as you guys know, and it smelled. And I was like, oh, no, oh, no. And we were rolling when it happened. And so it's in the bloopers. Here it is. Oh, God. Oh, God.
我给他发了短信。我说：“埃德，我能分享一下车里的那场戏吗？”他说：“可以，你可以告诉大家我在车里放屁了。”所以我们在车里，他应该舔一点我的冰淇淋，然后我得把它挤在旁边，对吧？拍了好几次才把那个挤压的动作拍好。在布置场景的间隙，他们得清理车门，我们就在布置间隙。埃德放了一个小屁。我当时怀孕了，你们知道的，味道很难闻。我说：“哦，不，哦，不。”我们当时正在拍摄，所以这被收录进了花絮里。就是这个。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。
I'm sorry. He drove you from the car. You had to get out. I had to get out of the car. And our crew was listening the whole time and they were cracking up. Ed is hitting the dashboard like, no, no, come back. I'm sorry. It cracks us up.
我很抱歉。他把你从车里赶出来了。你不得不下车。我不得不下车。我们的剧组人员一直在听，他们都笑翻了。埃德拍着仪表盘说：“不，不，回来。”我很抱歉。这把我们逗乐了。
It makes me laugh. Oh, my gosh. Years later, Jenna, when the show wrapped, Ed gave me the sweetest. card. He wrote all of these lovely things and he ended it with and I farted in a car with you so we'll always have that. Love Ed. It happens, but that one made the blooper real. Well, the very last scene is Dwight and Michael pulling up to this bus stop and as they pass by, we could see that Dwight's babysitter is waiting for the bus with her cooler. And, They do not offer her a ride.
这让我发笑。天哪，多年以后，珍娜，当剧集结束时，埃德给了我一张最贴心的卡片。他写了所有这些可爱的话，最后写道：“而且我在车里对你放了屁，所以我们永远会有那段回忆。爱你的埃德。”这种事确实会发生，但那一次被收进了花絮里。嗯，最后一个场景是德怀特和迈克尔开车来到公交车站，当他们经过时，我们可以看到德怀特的保姆正带着她的冷藏箱在等车。而且，他们没有提出载她一程。
It's terrible. But Beth Grant sent in a little memory of shooting this as well. I must say at the end, when I'm standing at the bus stop, waiting for the bus, because he hasn't even had the decency to drive me home. And his car pulls up, and we have this moment of looking at each other to me is so esoteric and brilliant and wonderful. And Raines look to me, and then he drives off. me at the bus stop. He's a free man. I just love how tickled she is by her whole storyline in this.
这太糟糕了。但贝丝·格兰特（Beth Grant）也发来了一段关于拍摄这一幕的小回忆。我必须说，在最后，当我站在公交车站等车时，因为他甚至没有礼貌地开车送我回家。他的车开过来，我们对视的那一刻，对我来说是如此深奥、精彩和美妙。雷恩（Rainn）看着我，然后他开车走了。我在公交车站。他是个自由人了。我真的很喜欢她对她整个故事线的这种自嘲感。
She was so game for all of it. And I loved having her on set. She was an absolute delight. Yes. And Beth, oh my goodness, thank you so much for sending in these audio clips. And thank you to Malora and Rain and John and Ed and Paul Feig, Gene and Lee, Kintapedia. Jenna, everyone really showed up for us for this episode. episode and Steve read the summary. Guys, that's dinner party. We hope you liked it. Angela and I worked extra long on this episode because we wanted to get everything we could
她对这一切都非常配合。我很高兴有她在片场。她绝对是个令人愉快的人。是的。还有贝丝，天哪，非常感谢你发来这些音频片段。也感谢梅洛拉、雷恩、约翰（John）、埃德、保罗·费格（Paul Feig）、吉恩（Gene）和李（Lee）、肯托百科。珍娜，每个人都为这一集全力以赴，史蒂夫读了总结。伙计们，这就是“晚宴”。希望你们喜欢。安吉拉和我为这一集付出了额外的努力，因为我们想尽可能多地获取内容
and share it with you. This is one of our favorite memories of shooting the show and we hope we did it justice. We love you guys so much. Thanks for listening. Go light your candles. Take a minute for yourself and find some serenity. Sam, will you take us out with just one night? That one night! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' second drink. This episode was
并与你们分享。这是我们拍摄这部剧最美好的回忆之一，希望我们没有辜负它。我们非常爱你们。感谢收听。去点上蜡烛吧。花点时间留给自己，寻找内心的宁静。萨姆（Sam），你能用《One Night》这首歌结束吗？那一个夜晚！感谢收听《办公室女士》（Office Ladies）的第二杯。这一集是
initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
最初与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·乔金斯（Cassie Jorkins），我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特（Molly Nugent）。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Shultz）混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。